Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Das Ganze hier, wie immer, ein Projekt der Metaebene in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Und ja, ich begrüße alle hier, nachdem wir in der letzten Folge mal ein sehr aktuelles Thema gehabt haben. Mit den Gravitationswellen geht es heute ein wenig in die andere Richtung. Heute gibt es einen Blick in die wissenschaftliche Vergangenheit. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht bleiben wir sogar beim Thema. Denn ich hatte mir schon länger gedacht, dass ich hier in dieser Serie auch mal einen Blick auf bestimmte Personen werfen möchte und auf bestimmte wissenschaftliche, grundlegende Erkenntnisse, die so gesammelt worden sind. Und womit könnte man da besser anfangen als mit Albert Einstein, der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie und den sonstigen Erkenntnissen, die dieser Mensch der Welt gebracht hat. Und um darüber zu sprechen, begrüße ich Jürgen Renn. Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit. Herr Renn, Sie sind Wissenschaftshistoriker und als solcher auch Direktor am Max-Planck-Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte in Berlin. Ich weiß gar nicht, es gibt gar nicht so viele Institutionen wie dieses, oder?
Es gibt sehr wenige. Die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft ist ja überwiegend naturwissenschaftlich orientiert. Wir haben aber auch eine geisteswissenschaftliche, sozialwissenschaftliche Sektion und da sind wir eines der Institute hier in Berlin. Es gibt auch die Wissenschaftsgeschichte natürlich an den Universitäten, leider nicht an sehr vielen Universitäten. In Berlin ist sie relativ stark präsent, aber weltweit kann man sagen, sind wir vielleicht eines der zentralen Institute für Wissenschaftsgeschichte.
Womit beschäftigt sich das Institut denn so im Wesentlichen?
Das Institut wurde 94 gegründet und es sollte eine besondere Art von Wissenschaftsgeschichte machen, nämlich eine, die nicht einfach sozusagen innerhalb der Disziplinen den Fortschritten der jeweiligen Fächer nachspürt, sondern eine, die nach den historischen Entwicklungen der fundamentalen Kategorien wissenschaftlichen Denkens fragt. Also Fragen wie Raum und Zeit, wenn wir gerade bei Raumzeit sind, aber auch Fragen wie Objektivität, wissenschaftliche Wahrheit. Wie haben sich solche fundamentalen Kategorien entwickelt und was waren die Faktoren? Welche Rolle haben Kontexte dabei gespielt? Kulturelle, wirtschaftliche, politische Kontexte. Und wie sieht so die langfristige Entwicklung dieser Dinge aus? Und was für ein Verständnis von Wissenschaft ergibt sich aus so einer Betrachtung? Ist das eine reine Fortschrittsgeschichte? Ist das eine Geschichte, die sich letztlich einordnet in eine politische oder eine Zeitgeschichte? Also dieses Spannungsverhältnis. Die Wissenschaft wurde ja traditionell als etwas gesehen, was sich sozusagen relativ autonom von der Gesellschaft entwickelte und so ihre eigene Logik hat und ihre eigene Fortschrittslogik sogar. Und dann gab es sozusagen in der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts, verbunden auch mit sehr starker Kritik an der Wissenschaft, den Versuch, die Wissenschaft letztlich wie eine andere kulturelle Praxis, wie jede andere kulturelle Praxis, auf ihre jeweiligen historischen Kontexte zurückzuführen, zu sagen, ah ja, da wird auch wie überall Einfluss genommen von Politik, wirtschaftlichen Interessen, persönlichen Interessen. Da wird viel geschummelt, wenn man so sagen will. Und da sind natürlich auch völlig neue Ansätze entstanden, die die Wissenschaft stärker mit ihren Kontexten in Verbindung bringen. Und ich sehe die Aufgabe des Instituts an, zwischen diesen beiden Extremen, also der reinen Geistesgeschichte der Wissenschaft auf der einen Seite, der Fortschrittsgeschichte und der sozusagen Kontextualisierung der Wissenschaft auf der anderen Seite zu vermitteln und die Wissenschaft als etwas zu begreifen, was zwar von solchen Kontexten und Einflüssen abhängt, aber doch der menschliche Versuch ist, Erkenntnisse, einer der besten Versuche, die wir haben, Erkenntnisse über die Natur und letztlich auch über uns selber zu erringen.
Was war denn so die Motivation dieses Instituts jetzt einzugehen? Also klar, die Zielsetzung wird mir klar, aber was hat dazu geführt, dass man dann auch so einen Schritt geht?
Also das war sicherlich auch ein politischer Kontext, der da eine Rolle gespielt hat. Das ist nicht lange nach der Wiedervereinigung gewesen und da hat die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft die Chance gehabt, durch die Wiedervereinigung neue Institute zu gründen und hat da zum Teil auch Traditionen aus der Akademie der Wissenschaften, der DDR und anderer DDR-Institutionen fortzusetzen, in denen Wissenschaftsgeschichte noch stärker als im Westen eigentlich präsent war. Das war die eine Seite, sozusagen die lokale Seite. Die andere Seite war die, dass die Wissenschaftsgeschichte in den angelsächsischen Ländern international eigentlich auch schon viel weiter entwickelt war und diese Richtung Kulturgeschichte der Wissenschaft, Wissenschaft als Teil der menschlichen Kultur, schon sehr viel stärker ausgelotet wurde, als das in Deutschland insgesamt der Fall war. Und da war das Institut eben eine Chance, einige der Traditionen, die es lokal gab, auch zum Teil innerhalb der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, etwa dem Max-Planck-Institut für Bildungsforschung, war das ein großes Thema Kultur und Kognition. Das aufzunehmen und in einen größeren internationalen Kontext zu stellen. Und man dachte sich von vornherein, die Wissenschaftsgeschichte nicht so als ein Orchideenfach, wie gesagt innerhalb der einzelnen Disziplinen zu betreiben, sondern interdisziplinär anzugehen. Also da spielt die Geschichte eine Rolle. Was die gesellschaftlichen Formationen betrifft, muss man die Gesellschaftswissenschaft, Soziologie und so weiter berücksichtigen. Aber eben Wissenschaft, da geht es um Erkenntnis, da geht es um Denken. Also brauchen wir auch die Kognitionsforschung, die kognitive Psychologie, die philosophische Epistemologie, aber jetzt nicht als Wissenschaften verstanden, die sich nur mit dem Denken des Einzelnen beschäftigen oder kulturenabhängig das Denken untersuchen, sondern eben historisch die Wissenschaft als auch eine Formation, wo viele Leute daran beteiligt sind, heute sehr viele Leute daran beteiligt sind, zu untersuchen und zu sehen, wie sich da Denkstile etwa verändert haben im Laufe der Zeit. Erkenntnisstrukturen verändert haben. Das ist so mit einem Wort die große Herausforderung. Man hat in der Wissenschaft, ich selber komme aus der Physik und mache dann eben auch hauptsächlich Physikgeschichte, da hat man dieses Phänomen, dass es auf der einen Seite eine Tradition gibt, die man von Aristoteles bis Einstein verfolgen kann, wo wirklich, wie Newton brümmterweise gesagt hat, man weitersehen konnte, weil man auf den Schultern von Riesen stand. Das ist die eine Seite, die Fortschrittsseite, aber auf der anderen Seite gab es eben immer wieder das, was Kuhn wissenschaftliche Revolutionen genannt hat. Also Umbrüche, auch in der Architektur des Wissens. Neue Begriffe von Raum und Zeit, völlig neues Verständnis von Kausalität, von Materie, von Strahlung und so weiter. Aber eben auch von dem, was wissenschaftliche Evidenz bedeutet, was die Kooperation von Theorie und Experiment bedeutet. Also wie versteht man, wie bringt man zusammen diese Umbrüche und diese Kontinuität? Und das kann man natürlich nur, wie gesagt, wenn man einen interdisziplinären Blick auf die Wissenschaft wirft, wie man das traditionellerweise eben nicht getan hat, wenn man die Wissenschaft nur als eine Leistung einzelner Heroen begreift. Ich verstehe zwar, dass ihr Podcast heute den Personen gewidmet ist, aber auch wenn man den Blick auf Albert Einstein richtet, kann man nicht nur die Person im Blick haben. Man muss auch die Situation der Wissenschaft zu seiner Zeit in den Blick nehmen. Das, was andere Wissenschaftler getan haben und das, worauf er aufgebaut hat. Denn nur so lässt sich sozusagen eine Lösung für dieses Paradox finden, dass wir auf der einen Seite so viel Kontinuität und auf der anderen Seite so viel fundamentale Umbrüche in der Wissenschaft haben.
Inwiefern ist denn diese Arbeit in dem Institut jetzt auch so in den Prozess der Ausbildung von Wissenschaftlern eingeflossen? Ich vermute mal, dass das ja auch eine der Motivationen ist, jetzt nicht nur hier für sich zu forschen, sondern sozusagen auch als Teil des Ausbildungssystems zu sehen.
Das ist in vielfältiger Weise gestehen, könnte aber sicherlich noch mehr geschehen, denn die Naturwissenschaften insbesondere, die stehen unter einem hohen Konkurrenzdruck, auch unter einem internationalen Konkurrenzdruck. Wir nehmen zwar Beispiele wie Einstein als einen Anlass dafür zu sagen, also Nachdenken, Reflexionen, Beschäftigung mit Grundlagen, auch Beschäftigung mit Fragen der Verantwortung für Wissenschaft, die sind ganz wichtig, auch für den Fortschritt der Wissenschaft. Aber im praktischen Lehrbetrieb spielt das eigentlich doch eine geringe Rolle, weil man sich konzentriert auf das, was man unbedingt braucht für seine Examiner, gerade sozusagen unter den heutigen Bedingungen. Ich habe ja noch zu einer Zeit studiert, wo man sich etwas freier bewegen konnte in den Fächern. Aber heute ist das alles sehr viel stärker zugeschnitten auf das, was man unbedingt machen muss, um relativ schnell dann die einzelnen Abschlüsse zu gewinnen. Und da könnten solche Reflexionsmomente eine größere Rolle spielen, als sie tatsächlich spielen. Sagen wir, auf vermittelte Weise findet das natürlich dennoch statt, weil wir allesamt am Institut unterrichten, weil wir Bücher schreiben, die hoffentlich auch für Studenten verständlich sind oder für Laien verständlich sind. Und weil wir natürlich in einen internationalen Prozess eingebunden sind. In anderen Ländern findet Wissenschaftsgeschichte ja auch statt und findet zum Teil eben auch als Teil von Ausbildungen statt. Da gibt es also auch in Amerika und anderen europäischen Ländern gute Beispiele. In Deutschland sind wir immer noch dabei, das stärker umzusetzen und stärker zu integrieren. Auch in Fachausbildung. Das wäre eher noch ein Ziel als bereits eine realisierte Praxis.
Aber es gibt so eine Art Konsens in der Ausbildungsszene, das zu verstärken?
So kann man es, glaube ich, nicht sagen, dass es da einen Konsens gibt. Wir beschäftigen uns halt nicht nur mit einer Wissenschaft. Wir beschäftigen uns mit Biologie, mit Chemie, auch mit den Geisteswissenschaften und ihrer Geschichte. Also da sind unterschiedliche Konsense, wenn sie so wollen, im Werk. In den Geisteswissenschaften ist es sehr viel selbstverständlicher, dass man sich auch mit der Geschichte des Fachs beschäftigt. In den Naturwissenschaften spielt das eigentlich eine marginale Rolle. Aber ich glaube, auch gerade in Gebieten wie Relativitätstheorie, wo es wirklich starke Umbrüche heute wieder gibt, wo es neue Entdeckungen gibt, da schaut man doch mit größerem Interesse auf die Vergangenheit zurück und guckt, was man daraus lernen kann. Und das Gleiche gilt natürlich für Fächer, wo man sehr stark auf Probleme auch gesellschaftlicher Art reflektieren muss. Also wenn wir heute über Anwendungen von Großtechnologien reden, über Energiewende und dergleichen mehr, dann kommt man natürlich auch nicht aus ohne Reflexion darüber, wie ist man früher mit Ressourcen umgegangen, was bedeutet das für Gesellschaftsstrukturen. Und da gibt es immer wieder Dinge, wir machen jetzt nächste Woche zum Beispiel mit dem Haus der Kulturen der Welt eine große Veranstaltung zum Thema Anthropozäen. Das neue geologische Zeitalter der Menschheit, das stark reflektiert auf die Tatsache, dass Menschen ihre Umwelt doch weitgehend machen, auch wenn sie sie in dem berühmten magischen Wort eben nicht bewusst machen. Unfreiwillig machen sie sie, gestalten den Planeten um. Und das spielt natürlich überall eine Rolle, wenn man über Technologien nachdenkt, dass man auch die gesellschaftlichen Bedingungen unter den Technologien eingesetzt wird, die globalen Auswirkungen, auch lokale Aktionen, mitbedenken muss. Und was wir da mit dem Haus der Kulturen zusammen machen, ist tatsächlich ein Seminar, zu dem Studenten aus der ganzen Welt, eben aber auch Lehrende aus der ganzen Welt kommen. Und in dem wir völlig fächerübergreifend, das geht wirklich von der Geologie über die Architektur bis zur Physik und den Geisteswissenschaften, nachdenken über diese menschheitsgeschichtlichen Prozesse, die da unseren Planeten beeinflusst haben und gerade beeinflussen. Also das geht alles ganz über Disziplingrenzen hinweg. Aber ich glaube, es ist nicht ganz untypisch. Wir befinden uns ja hier auch in einer, sagen wir mal, nicht klassischen Institution, in keinem öffentlichen Rundfunk und in keiner etablierten Zeitschrift oder einem Radiosender. Das heißt, viele dieser Informationsvermittlungen, die finden außerhalb des klassischen Lehrangebotes statt. Auch dass eine öffentliche Institution, wie das Haus der Kultur in der Welt und Max-Bank-Institut, sich da zusammentun, das ist ja eher ungewöhnlich. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch den Themen geschuldet, weil die erst mal auch nicht reinpassen in so einen etablierten Fächerkanon. Dieses Nachdenken hat erst mal keine Grenzen, die man so kennt klassischerweise aus den Disziplinen.
Ja, und das Internet ist natürlich auch kräftig dabei, überhaupt einen zweiten Lehrraum zu schaffen, wenn es nicht längst schon so weit ist. Indem man sich ja im Prinzip auch vollständig, unabhängig von solchen Strukturen, im Prinzip Wissen aneignen kann.
Da stimme ich Ihnen vollkommen zu. Das Internet sehe ich da als eine große Chance, wenn es eben als öffentlicher Raum erhalten bleibt. Denn wenn man die Tendenzen beobachtet, die es natürlich sehr stark gibt, das Internet auch sozusagen stärker zu privatisieren und Standards nicht mehr zu berücksichtigen, dann oder es einfach zu instrumentalisieren und zu kommerzialisieren, dann schränkt man natürlich diese Freiräume erheblich ein. Also es gibt zwar Lehrangebote, man redet über diese MOOCs, aber die haben oft eben viel stärker klassische traditionelle Züge, als sie es haben müssten. Das Internet ist ja im Prinzip ein sehr interaktives Medium und da kann sehr viel stärker miteinander vernetzt werden, als das in anderen traditionellen Massenmedien der Fall ist, wo man immer einen Sender und viele Empfänger hat. Dieses Potenzial ist aus meiner Sicht noch nicht ausgeschöpft, gerade für eine Organisation des Wissens. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass diese Entwicklung dazu beitragen wird, klassische Disziplingrenzen zu überwinden und Wissen auch neu zu organisieren. Ich sehe das Internet als eine Riesenchance an, auf Menschheitsprobleme mit einer Art Menschheitsbewusstsein zu reagieren, dass ich nur über solche Kommunikationsprozesse herstellen kann.
Ich merke schon, Sie beschäftigen sich nicht nur mit der Geschichte, sondern mit dem zeitlichen Verlauf und blicken auch in dem selben Maße in die Zukunft.
Ja, die Dinge hängen ja auch zusammen. Wir beschäftigen uns am Institut mit Fragen wie der Entstehung der Schrift oder mit dem Medienwandel, den etwa der Buchdruck herbeigeführt hat. Medien und wissenschaftliche Inhalte und auch soziale Verhältnisse, unter denen Inhalte entstehen und vermittelt werden, hängen natürlich aufs Ängste zusammen. Die Hoffnung von Historikern ist oder sollte sein, dass man nicht Rezepte daraus extrahieren kann, aber dass man doch lernen kann, die Gegenwart und die Zukunft unter einer breiteren Perspektive sieht, die die Erfahrungen, die wir gesammelt haben als Menschheit, etwa mit solchen, ich habe jetzt zwei Beispiele genannt, mit Ressourcen wechseln, also was bedeutet das jetzt, eine Energiewende zu machen vor dem Hintergrund unserer Erfahrungen, mit Ressourcen, ebenso was bedeutet das, ein neues Medium einzuführen, vor dem Hintergrund der vielfältigen Erfahrungen, die wir bereits haben im Umgang mit neuen Medien. Also was man zum Beispiel aus der Geschichte des Buchdrucks, aber auch aus der Geschichte der Schrift lernen kann, ist, dass die Formate, die sich dann entwickeln, also hier beispielsweise das Format, in dem heute Wissenschaft publiziert wird, die Fachzeitschriften, die Bücher, das hat eine lange Zeit gebraucht, bis die entstanden sind, aus sozusagen einem Ausloten der Möglichkeiten. Wenn man diese einfache Tatsache mal berücksichtigt, dann sieht man, wie kurzschlüssig das ist, einfach diese Formate jetzt in das neue Medium, Internet oder elektronisches Medium, zu übersetzen. Warum müssen zukünftige wissenschaftliche Publikationen die Form eines Zeitschriftenartikels oder einer Buchpublikation haben? Informationseinheiten können völlig anders strukturiert werden. Die Links, die Vernetzung von Wissen, das gehört zum Wesen des Wissens. Und wir haben jetzt völlig neue Möglichkeiten, diese Vernetzung zum Ausdruck zu bringen. Da müssen wir natürlich hoch aufpassen, dass wir, sag ich mal, als Öffentlichkeit, als Wissenschaftler, aber auch alle, die von Wissenschaft profitieren oder was lernen wollen, dass diese Vernetzungsstrukturen uns auch zugänglich sind und nicht einfach nur sozusagen von Google und anderen als ein Potential vorgehalten werden, mit dem man einen kommerziellen Gewinn erzielen kann. Ich glaube, diese Vernetzungsstrukturen sind ein wesentlicher Teil des Menschheitswissens. Wir müssen die Form finden, in der wir sie wahrnehmen können, bearbeiten können, mit ihnen spielen und interagieren können, um einfach das Wissen, das wir brauchen, um unsere Zukunfts-Herausforderungen anzugehen, uns auch wirklich zu erarbeiten und dann auch kommunizieren zu können. Wenn das alles hinter, wie wir sagen, Paywalls und Zöllen und so weiter verborgen bleibt, dann fühle ich mich als Wissenschaftler, der einer öffentlichen Institution angehört, eigentlich ein bisschen um meinen Ertrag gebracht. Denn wenn ich mein Wissen nicht offen verfügbar machen kann, sondern nur über diese Schranken verfügbar machen kann, dann findet es einfach nicht den Impact, den es eigentlich haben könnte.
Das ist ja so Bestandteil der Open-Science-Diskussion. Auch dieses Ganze, wie veröffentliche ich, wie zitiere ich, dieses Wesen umzustellen, ist ja eine aktive Debatte, die vielleicht noch nicht laut genug geführt wird, aber unvermeidlich zu sein scheint. Bevor wir vielleicht auf Albert Einstein kommen, würde mich noch mal kurz interessieren, wie sie selber so in die Wissenschaft geraten sind. Sicherlich war ja die Arbeit in der Historie jetzt nicht unbedingt das allererste Ziel. Sie hatten schon gesagt, Physik hatten sie verfolgt. Das war dann auch so ihr erster Spiel.
Als junger Mensch war ich Amateurastronom und begeistert von Beobachtungen, auch von so einer Gemeinschaft, die es da gab. Ich habe als 14-, 15-Jähriger angefangen, einen Fernrohr bekommen von meinen Eltern und dann angefangen zu beobachten. Dann habe ich sehr schnell entdeckt, dass es da andere gibt und dass das auch so eine Art internationale Vernetzung gibt unter den Amateurastronomen. Eigentlich war mein ursprüngliches Berufsziel, dann Astronom zu werden. Da muss man Physik studieren und so bin ich in die Physik hineingekommen. Dann habe ich mich sehr schnell auch angefangen, für gesellschaftliche Fragen zu interessieren und habe dann so ein bisschen meinen Blick ausgeweitet und habe lange Zeit versucht, beides parallel zu machen, die Physik und dann diese, ich habe dann Philosophie studiert und auch Geschichte und habe mich dann so umgeguckt. Damals hatte man wirklich diese Freiheit, ich glaube ich in größerem Maße, als man sie heute so vom Zuschnitt des Studiums hatte. Ich habe dann Physik aber abgeschlossen und bin nach meiner Promotion dann zur Ausgabe der Werke von Albert Einstein gekommen. Das war sozusagen meine erste Position nach dem Abschluss des Studiums. Ich bin dann nach Amerika gegangen an die Boston University und habe dort eigentlich sozusagen unmittelbar von der Physik kommt als Wissenschaftshistoriker weitergemacht, weil ich mich halt mit den Inhalten schon beschäftigt hatte im Rahmen meines Physikstudiums, aber gleichzeitig diese historischen Interessen inzwischen entwickelt hatte. Und das war für mich ein ideales Sprungbrett, um genau dieses Beides miteinander zu verbinden. Also bin ich da rein geraten.
Also Albert Einstein war ein Thema. Und er ist ja auch heute noch ein Thema. Wie schon angedeutet, auch die letzte Sendung hier drehte sich letzten Endes auch irgendwie um ihn, weil ja in seinen Werken auch die Existenz von Gravitationswellen im Prinzip vorhergesagt worden ist. Und überhaupt waren so die letzten Jahre nochmal enorm von weiterer Bestätigung seiner Thesen geprägt. Aber vielleicht dann mal einfach mal 100, 110 Jahre vielleicht jetzt zurück. Ist ja nun wirklich mal eine ganz andere Zeit, wo wir zunehmend in Maße Schwierigkeiten haben, uns das vorzustellen, wie das gesellschaftliche Leben und insbesondere wie auch so das wissenschaftliche Dasein gewesen ist. Ich glaube auch, dass eigentlich auch die Rolle, Wissenschaft zu betreiben, Wissenschaftler zu sein, auch überhaupt nicht vergleichbar ist mit der heutigen Situation, oder?
Ja, da stimme ich Ihnen vollkommen zu. Erstmal war die Wissenschaft viel kleiner, die ist ja heute sozusagen industrialisiert geradezu. Und die Leute, die damals sich mit solchen Fragen wie Einstein beschäftigt hat, das war eine Handvoll Leuten in Deutschland, in der Schweiz. Und dann gab es natürlich schon eine europäische Gemeinschaft. Also international war die Wissenschaft schon. Und da war es dann natürlich auch nicht mehr nur eine Handvoll. Aber die Community, die war immer noch so klein, dass man sich im Grunde relativ schnell dann gegenseitig kennengelernt hatte oder kannte. Es war auch die Zeit, wo dann die ersten internationalen Konferenzen stattfanden. Aber es war noch eine Zeit, wo jemand, deren Außenseiter war, wie Einstein, denn der Einstein hatte nach seinem Studium ja erst mal einen Job am Patentamt bekommen in Bern, in der Schweiz, und hat dann neben seinen Pflichttätigkeiten am Patentamt über grundlegende Probleme nachgedacht. Und hat dann noch, als er am Patentamt war, praktisch eine Revolution in der Physik ausgelöst. Aus seinen ersten Papieren, die dann wirklich revolutionär waren, sind 1905 erschienen. Da hat er die spezielle Relativitätstheorie formuliert. Da hat er die Theorie der Braunschen Bewegung formuliert, die dann eine wichtige Bestätigung geworden ist für die Existenz von Atomen. Und er hat die Lichtquantenhypothese aufgestellt. Also das, was wir heute Photonen nennen. Also ein ganz wichtiger Schritt in der Entwicklung der Quantentheorie. Und das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Das hat ein junger Mann sozusagen als Patentamtsangestellter 3. Klasse in Bern gemacht.
Also er war ja eigentlich, also muss ich das so vorstellen, er war in keinerlei wissenschaftlichen Apparat in dem Sinne zu Hause.
Er war in dem Sinne, sondern er hatte sogar versucht, natürlich eine Stelle zu kriegen. Sein Vater hat dann Briefe an deutsche Professoren geschrieben und bitte nehmt auch meinen Sohn als Assistenten und so weiter. Aber er war dann froh, dass er durch einen Freund, Marcel Grossmann, dann diese Stelle am Patentamt bekommen hat. Und das war zunächst mal ein ganz gutes Auskommen, aber er war halt kein Profi, wenn man so will. Aber, und das ist jetzt das Wichtige, das bringt eigentlich sozusagen wieder so ein Schlaglicht zurück auf diese Frage des Internets. Wieso konnte er das machen? Also ich sag mal so, nicht jeder Spinner kann eine wissenschaftliche Revolution auslösen, auch wenn viele das glauben. Also eine wichtige Voraussetzung war, dass Einstein Zugang zum zeitgenössischen Wissen hatte. Und das hatte er, weil es damals wissenschaftliche Zeitschriften gab, weil es Lehrbücher gab, weil es die Großen seiner Zeit, Leute wie Helmholtz oder Planck, bereits ihr Wissen dokumentiert haben in Lehrbüchern, die man natürlich lesen und studieren konnte und sich somit auf den Diskussionsstand der Zeit bewegen konnte. Ich finde es immer so ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass der Zugang zu Wissen entscheidend ist für die Mitwirkung am Wissen. Also Wissen muss verfügbar sein. Und es war es. Einstein war natürlich hervorragend da ausgestattet mit Zeitschriften und Bibliotheken in Bern und konnte als jemand, der zwar noch nicht bekannt oder in der Community war, aber gleich einsteigen auf dem Stand der Diskussion seiner Zeit. Dass die eine Seite, also die Zugang und Teilhabe, die andere Seite ist natürlich, dass er als totaler Außenseiter eine ganz andere Perspektive auf dieses Wissen hatte als diejenigen, die im Betrieb drin waren. Die bereits sozusagen Schüler eines Meisters waren und sozusagen die ganzen Standardinterpretationen dieses Wissens übernommen hat. Was Einstein im Grunde gemacht hat, und das bringt eigentlich seine Revolution von 1905 auf einen Begriff, er hat das Standardwissen hergenommen und hat ihm eine neue Interpretation gegeben. Das ist besonders eindrücklich bei der speziellen Relativitätstheorie. Da gab es einen Großmeister der damaligen Physik, den Hendrik Anton Lorenz, ein holländischer Physiker, der also die aktuelle Theorie der Elektrodynamik, und dazu gehörte natürlich auch die Optik, aufgestellt hat. Und das Spezialproblem der Elektrodynamik in bewegten Körpern, also wie verhält sich das Licht in einem bewegten Bezugssystem, das hat er alles perfekt ausgebaut auf experimenteller Basis, die damals weitgehend gegeben war durch eine Vielzahl von Experimenten. Aber er hatte auch eine mathematisch sehr raffinierte Theorie entwickelt. Und im Grunde kann man diese Geschichte so erzählen, dass Einstein sich mit diesem Werk vertraut gemacht hat. Und nun statt einiger Hilfshypothesen, die Lorenz eingeführt hatte, um diese Schwierigkeiten einer Elektrodynamik und optikbewegter Körper zu erklären, hat Einstein gesagt, da braucht man neue Raum- und Zeitbegriffe. Da muss man jetzt nicht den Äther nehmen und nachdenken, warum spürt man diesen Äther-Wind nicht, wenn man sich durch den bewegt. Der Äther ist das Medium, in dem sich elektromagnetische Wellen nach der damaligen Auffassung fortbewegt haben und eben auch das Licht transportierte, weil man konnte sich keine Welle ohne ein Medium vorstellen. Schallwellen brauchen die Luft, Wasserwellen brauchen das Wasser, elektromagnetische Wellen brauchen den Äther. Aber da kommt man schnell zu schwierigen Annahmen, weil wenn so ein Medium da ist, dann muss es irgendwelche mechanischen Eigenschaften haben. Aber man konnte sich keine vernünftige mechanische Theorie ausdenken und dann kam Einstein dann zu der Lösung, brauchen wir nicht, sondern wir müssen noch mal grundsätzlich nachdenken über unsere Begriffe von Raum und Zeit und dann kann man diese Probleme lösen. Das heißt, Einstein hat sozusagen den höchst entwickelten Stand der Physik seiner Zeit genommen und hat ihm eine neue grundsätzliche Interpretation gegeben. Und das konnte er tun, jetzt habe ich es sehr schlagwortartig gesagt, weil er Außenseiter war, aber er war natürlich auch in anderer Hinsicht ein informierter Außenseiter, weil er sich sehr stark mit erkenntnistheoretischen und philosophischen Überlegungen vertraut gemacht hatte. Und er war, das ist vielleicht die dritte Komponente, er war nicht alleine, sondern hatte so einen Kreis von Gleichgesinnten um sich. Da gehörte der Marcel Grossmann dazu, das war ein Mathematiker, da war der Michele Besso dabei, das war ein Ingenieur, da war seine spätere Frau, die Miliva Maric dabei, da waren die Brüder Habich dabei, Leute, die dann später mit Einstein zusammen die sogenannte Akademie Olympia gegründet haben, so ein Debatierclub. Und die haben sich alle möglichen Bälle zugeworfen, haben Literatur gelesen, die haben aber auch Philosophie gelesen. Die haben sich relativ breit informiert. Und das hat natürlich das Entstehen so einer unabhängigen Perspektive sehr stark gefördert.
Also sehr interdisziplinär aufgestellter Freundeskreis, für die, dass man so interpretieren darf, der ausgetretenen Pfad eh irgendwie uninteressant war, vor allem weil sie ihn auch gar nicht so sehr kannten. In dem Moment, wo man jetzt in so einem Ausbildungsbetrieb drin ist und dann an irgendeinem Professor dranhängt, der schon immer irgendeine These vertreten hat, dann tendiert man ja schnell dazu, nur das, was da sozusagen schon die ganze Zeit gedacht wurde, irgendwie zu verfeinern oder zu erweitern, aber vielleicht nicht unbedingt als erstes grundsätzlich in Frage zu stellen. Kann man das auch so sehen, dass er da jetzt auch gar nicht unbedingt so einen revolutionären Ansatz an als Seuchen verfolgen wollte, sondern einfach nur durch seine andere Herangehensweise quasi die Gabe entwickelt hat, die Dinge neu zusammenzusetzen.
Also ein rebellischer Geist gehört schon dazu. Also wenn Sie sagen, man folgt dann als Student seinem Lehrer und so, da sind ja auch psychologische und soziale Zwänge dabei. Und von denen, wenn man da nicht so nah dran ist, ist man ein Stück weit befreit. Aber was hinzukommt, ist, wenn man sich selber so als Rebell empfindet, was diese jungen Leute damals getan haben, die waren schon so anti-establishment eingerichtet. Das bezog sich auch auf Familien, wie geht man mit Familie und den konservativen Werten der Zeit um. Die haben sich schon sehr rebellisch gefühlt. Und bei Einstein speziell haben sicherlich auch frühe Lektüren eine Rolle gespielt, der ist ja als junger Mann durch alle möglichen Phasen gegangen. Seine Eltern waren nicht-religiöse Juden. Einstein hat dann als junger Mann mal eine Phase durchgemacht, wo er sich dann sozusagen religiös selbst verstanden hat. Dann im Widerspruch zu den Eltern versucht hat, sozusagen eine religiöse Haltung einzunehmen. Dann hat er aber angefangen populärwissenschaftliche Bücher zu lesen, ist da sehr schnell wieder von abgekommen, hat dann plötzlich die Bibel als eine Sammlung von Lügen angesehen und hat sich sehr stark mit sozusagen auch seiner gesellschaftlichen Umwelt beschäftigt. Also durch diese Bücher, das ist vielleicht auch ein interessanter historischer Zusammenhang, die Bücher, die Einstein damals gelesen hat, die sind alle so von Leuten geschrieben worden, die an der 1848er Demokratischen Revolution noch beteiligt waren. Und es sind dann Leute gewesen, die versucht haben, Demokratie mit Wissenschaft zu verbinden. Und das Unternehmen Wissenschaft von vornherein auch als so ein internationales und demokratisches Unternehmen ohne Grenzen betrachtet haben. Und das hat Einstein, glaube ich, sehr stark auf seinen Wissenschaftsbegriff gebracht. Er hat es immer schon so dann empfunden, schon als junger Mann, dass Wissenschaft eigentlich weder über Disziplinen noch über Nationalitäten, geschweige denn Kulturen, Rassen und so weiter, irgendwelche Grenzen kennen sollte. Und das ist eine Haltung, die sich dann nochmal verstärkt hat, als er dann als junger Mann noch vor dem Studium in die Schweiz gekommen ist, dann bei einer Familie untergekommen ist, die auch sehr stark liberale Haltungen gepflegt hat und in der Schweiz dann auch nochmal so eine Art Modelldemokratie kennengelernt hat. Alles das hat auch den politischen Einstein sehr stark geprägt. Und das war eben jemand, der weder politisch noch in der Wissenschaft sich vor Autoritäten gebeugt hat. Und auch dann natürlich die Gegenbewegung gegenüber dem, was er in Deutschland in der Schule kennengelernt hat, was er im damaligen Deutschland an Militarismus kennengelernt hat. Das sind alles Dinge, von denen er sich abgesetzt hat. Und das ist Zeit lebens, hat das seine Haltung geprägt.
Was mich nochmal interessieren würde, bevor wir vielleicht auf seine Konk... vor allem auf die Relativitätstheorie, mit der es ja auch irgendwie angefangen hat, eingehen. Wie muss man sich den wissenschaftlichen Kenntnisstand der Welt oder zumindest aus europäischer Perspektive vorstellen? Ich meine, heutzutage sieht man schon so viel als gegeben und gesetzt an. Wir wissen, wie viele Planeten es gibt, etc., pp. Oder zumindest glauben wir gerade zu wissen, wie viele es gibt. Jetzt ist ja auch schon wieder nicht ganz klar.
Ich würde immer so sagen, inzwischen sind es wieder neun.
Jetzt sind es wieder neun, genau. Also wir wissen denn etwa, wie viele Planeten es gibt. Aber die Zeit war ja nun auch geprägt von ganz grundlegenden Erkenntnissen, die im Prinzip erst so die Basis gelegt haben für die moderne Technologie, die wir heute als gegeben voraussetzen. Was, ich will jetzt nicht den kompletten Wissenstand zu dem Zeitpunkt festhalten, aber vielleicht gibt es so ein paar markante Punkte, was man sozusagen alles noch nicht gewusst hat, was man heutzutage so als selbstverständlich ansehen sollte, die einen auch davon abgebracht haben könnten, ein größeres Bild zu entwickeln. Also es klang jetzt schon an mit dem Äther, das ist ja schon so eine Chimäre gewesen, weil man sich es halt nicht vorstellen konnte. Hatte man eben so ein Ding? Gab es da noch so andere Bereiche des Unwissens, die so dominiert haben?
Also erstmal würde ich fast das Ungekehrte betonen. Man hatte damals schon ein Selbstverständnis, dass man schon ziemlich am Ende der Erkenntnis angelangt wäre. Also, dass man ein Wissenschaft...
Nichts mehr zu erfinden.
Genau, alles Wesentliche ist schon gemacht. Es gibt ein wissenschaftliches Weltbild, also die damalige Physik zumal hatte schon von sich selber die Auffassung, es gibt die berühmte Geschichte, dass der Plank, der nicht sicher war, ob er nun Musik machen sollte, Philosophie, Physik und so weiter, von seinem Lehrer abgeraten bekommen hat, in die Physik zu gehen, weil die ja im Grunde schon fast fertig sei. Und das war so doch ein Selbstverständnis. Und in der Tat ist es ja auch nicht völlig falsch, sondern man hat ja die großen Bereiche der Wissenschaft. Denken Sie mal, Darwin gab es schon, Newton gab es schon, es gab Präzisionsmessungen in der Astronomie. Also es konnte schon so scheinen.
Es gab auch spektakuläre technische Errungenschaften, Eisenbahnen.
Absolut, die Anfänge der Automobile und der Motoren. Der Funkverbindung ist nicht alles jetzt genau in dieser Zeit, aber man hatte schon eine sehr starke Aufbruchstimmung. Übrigens in Klammern gesagt, Einsteins Familienhintergrund ist auch. Das ist eine Familie, die hat sich mit Elektrotechnik beschäftigt. Die haben Dynamos und Motoren entwickelt, waren an der Elektrifizierung von Städten beteiligt. Also man hatte schon das Gefühl, wenn man auch noch nicht alles erfunden hatte und wusste, das war eine Zeit des Aufbruchs. Das ist die eine Perspektive darauf. Weltausstellung. Denken Sie sozusagen auch an das Phänomen der Globalisierung. Man hatte damals schon den Eindruck, auch die Welt ist im Wesentlichen oder die berühmten Geschichten von Jules Verne, die einem auch den Eindruck vermitteln, dass man in einer technisierten, beherrschbaren Welt lebt damals.
Und auch schon die passenden Visionen für die nächsten Zeit bereitgelegt hat. Reise zum Mond.
Reise zum Mond. Alles das war doch schon im Bewusstsein der Leute. Zum Teil noch Utopie, aber jedenfalls technische und erreichbare Utopie. Okay, das ist die eine Seite. Die andere Seite ist, wenn man von heute zurückblickt, was daran wirklich nur Utopie war. Also, dass wir sozusagen unsere Städte mit Luftschiffen verkehren. Das ist so eine Vorstellung der Zeit, das sind sicherlich Utopien. Den Computer konnte sich kein Mensch vorstellen in dieser Zeit. Undenkbar. Auch viel später noch haben die Leute Visionen gehabt, dass ein Computer so groß sein muss wie ein Haus, um das zu bewerkstellen, was wir heute mit unseren Mobilfonds machen. Also es gab wirklich Überraschungen. Vom Internet will ich gar nicht reden. Aber man muss sich klarmachen, dass solche Utopien immer Extrapolationen dessen sind, was man gerade in der Zeit hat. Relevant für unser Thema hier ist, dass man sich von der Größe des Universums kaum eine Vorstellung macht. Es war damals eigentlich noch nicht klar, ob es im Universum außer unserer Milchstraße was gibt. Es war immer noch nicht klar, ob die kleinen Fleckchen, Leute wie Herschel und andere hatten zwar schon darüber spekuliert, aber es war letztlich nicht klar, dass es sozusagen eine Struktur gibt, bei der unsere Milchstraße eine Galaxie unter vielen Galaxien ist. Geschweige denn, dass das Universum dynamisch ist, dass es sich ausdehnt, dass da heftige Prozesse stattfinden. Also wenn man auf den gestirnten Himmel, das berühmte Wort von Kant, mal hochblickt, dann hat man das Gefühl einer ungeheuren Stabilität. Das hat ja lange das Bild des Kosmos geprägt. Und das war auch noch im 19. Jahrhundert und am Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts der Fall. Im Grunde war das sogar noch Einsteins Weltbild, auch das astronomische Weltbild. Also als Einstein dann angefangen hat, nach der speziellen die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie zu entwickeln und sie dann aufs Universum anzuwenden, da war seine Vorstellung vom Universum zunächst mal die eines statischen Kosmos, in dem alles schön fest geordnet ist, in dem sich auch nichts groß verändert. Und die Funktion dieses statischen Kosmos war für Einstein im Wesentlichen, die Vorgänge hier lokal auf der Erde oder im Planetensystem zu erklären. Dass es da wahnsinnige Prozesse gibt, die genau seine Theorie wiederum erklären würde, das konnte er sich nicht vorstellen. Zeit seines Lebens im Grunde nicht.
Schmerkenswert, dass er überhaupt sich irgendwas nicht vorstellen konnte, wo er schon so viel erdacht hat, was man sich nicht vorstellen kann. Also das war wahrscheinlich sogar noch der signifikanteste Unterschied, dass diese Vorstellung der Gesamtwelt des Universums oder der Multiversen, was auch immer noch dahinter liegen mag, so eigentlich noch gar nicht da war. Dass man eigentlich noch sehr lokal dachte.
Das kann man so sagen, ja. So lokal und statisch. Also, obwohl man damals natürlich schon, wie gesagt, in einer Fortschrittseuphorie lebte, ich glaube, lagen die Beschleunigungen, die es in der Entwicklung von Wissenschaft und Technik dann im 20. Jahrhundert gegeben hat, geschweige denn die großen Katastrophen, die es, die Zivilisationskatastrophen, die es dann im 20. Jahrhundert gab, zunächst noch mal ziemlich weit außerhalb der Vorstellungskraft. Aber ich meine, Einstein hat ja dann auch beides noch durchlebt. Er hat ja die zwei Weltkriege durchlebt und die Katastrophen wahrgenommen. Er hat natürlich auch weitere technische Errungenschaften noch mitgekriegt. Er hat ja eine Funkausstellung hier in Berlin eröffnet und zunächst mal großen Optimismus mit dem neuen Medium Radio verbunden, weil er glaubte, nun könnte man sozusagen größere Transparenz auch politisch damit erreichen.
Denke auch daran, dass die Techniker es sind, die erst wahre Demokratie möglich machen. Denn sie erleichtern nicht nur das Menschen-Tagewerk, sondern machen auch die Werke der feinsten Denker und Künstler, deren Genuss noch vor kurzem ein Privileg bevorzugter Klassen war, der Gesamtheit zugänglich und erwecken so die Völker aus schläfriger Stumpfheit. Eines meiner Lieblingszitate von Albert Einstein, das hat er ja im Rahmen dieser Öffnungsrede gesagt, ja, das klingt so ein bisschen nach jemanden, der einerseits optimist ist oder vielleicht auch einfach sein will, aber auch ein bisschen dran glaubt, dass das Sein Wirken gute Auswirkungen haben kann auf alles.
Das hat er ja versucht und er hat sich natürlich auch vor diesem Wirken, er ist vor diesem Wirken nicht zurückgescheut. Das heißt, als dann irgendwann er zu einer Berühmtheit wurde, was ja lange Zeit auch nicht absehbar war, wir waren jetzt sozusagen biografisch noch am Patentamt, später machte er dann eine akademische Karriere, aber die führt ja auch nicht automatisch zur Berühmtheit. Zur Berühmtheit ist er erst 1919 geworden, als die Lichtablenkung, die seiner Allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie vorhergesagt wird, also dass auch das Licht im schweren Feld unterliegt und dass wenn man Sternenlicht beobachtet, dass es so knapp an der Sonne vorbeigeht, dann von der Sonne abgelenkt wird. Das kann man natürlich nur bei einer Sonnenfinsternis beobachten. Als das dann 1919 bestätigt wurde von einer englischen Expedition, kurz nach dem Ende des ersten Weltkriegs, da war das eine internationale Sensation, weil man die Wissenschaft hier nochmal deutlich vor Augen geführt bekam, als in ihrem Wesen eine internationale Kooperation. Ein Deutscher, Schweizer, Jude macht eine Theorie, eine englische Expedition bestätigt das. Das war wirklich gerade in dieser Zeit symbolhaft. Das hat Einsteins Aufstieg zu einem Medienstab befördert. Das war jetzt sozusagen nur der Einschub. Was man dann eben sieht, ist, wie stark dieser eigene Karriere, dieser Umgang mit den Medien, Einstein auch bewusst gewesen ist, als ein Potential, das er wiederum für seine Botschaften nutzen konnte. Er hat den Aufstieg der Massenmedien erlebt und hat ihn einfach nicht nur passiv erlebt, so wie man dann plötzlich exponiert ist, sondern er hat dann versucht wiederum, die Kanäle, die sich da entwickelten, zu nutzen für solche Botschaften, wie wir sie gerade gehört haben.
Kommen wir dann nochmal auf den Beginn seines Schaffens. Er war im Prinzip ein Außenseiter, aber er hat sich halt intensiv mit den Technologien und Wissenschaften, soweit sie ihm zugänglich waren, beschäftigt. Die Bibliothek war sein Internet. Sein Freundeskreis hat dafür gesorgt, dass er sich auch sehr interdisziplinär und hinterfragend mit den Themen auseinandergesetzt hat. Und während er also in diesem Patentamt so seinen täglichen Dingen machte, wo ja seine Arbeit eigentlich in keinerlei Form, also insofern natürlich wissenschaftlich war, als dass er es mit Patentanträgen, also mehr dem Ingenieurstum wahrscheinlich nahestehend zu tun hatte, hat er im Prinzip die ganze Zeit im Hinterkopf genutzt, um einfach über diese Dinge nachzudenken, die ihm einfach den Schlaf geraubt haben, wahrscheinlich in gewisser Hinsicht. Was genau war denn jetzt sozusagen seine erste grundlegende Erkenntnis? Was ist mit dieser speziellen Relativität 1905 überhaupt in den Fokus geraten?
Ja, was damit in den Fokus geraten ist, ist, dass diese wissenschaftlichen Probleme, die es damals in der Physik gab, die zunächst mal sehr speziell aussehen, also wie geht man um mit der Tatsache, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer die gleiche zu sein scheint und sich jedenfalls nicht so verhält wie andere Geschwindigkeiten. Also das berühmte Beispiel, jemand läuft in einem Zug, jemand am Bahnsteig beobachtet das und kann jetzt einfach die beiden Geschwindigkeiten addieren. Der Zug bewegt sich, weiß ich, mit 150 kmh, der Fußgänger bewegt sich nochmal mit 7 kmh in der Richtung des Zuges, dann sieht der Beobachter am Bahndamm ihn mit 157 kmh von sich weg bewegen oder eben 143 kmh, wenn er sich in die andere Richtung bewegt. Also addieren sich halt normale Geschwindigkeiten, würde man denken, so würde es die klassische Physik. Aber wenn der Beobachter jetzt sieht, dass der Fußgänger nicht läuft, sondern seine Taschenlampe anknipst im Zug mit einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit C, die Lichtgeschwindigkeit, dann würde man ja vermuten, dass auch da die gleiche Addition stattfindet. Also wenn der Lichtstrahl in der Richtung des Zuges geht, dann muss man die Geschwindigkeit des Zuges und die Geschwindigkeit des Lichtes addieren. Anders muss man sie subtrahieren. Und nun stellt mal fest, ich vereinfache das jetzt sehr stark, weil die Experimente natürlich sehr viel schwieriger sind und auch anders formuliert worden sind, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer die gleiche ist. Das ist eigentlich ein Paradox.
In beide Richtungen?
In beide Richtungen und unabhängig davon, ob ich mich mit dem Fahrgast im Zug befinde oder ob ich da am Bahnsteig stehe, ich sehe die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer als dieselbe, rund 300.000 km pro Sekunde. Und wenn man schon mal so weit ist, hat man fast das Problem schon gelöst, weil man dann erkannt hat, es muss ein Problem sein, das mit fundamentalen Fragen von Raum und Zeit, mit der Messung von Geschwindigkeiten usw. zu tun hat. Deswegen sage ich, ich stelle das sehr vereinfacht jetzt da. Einstein hat eine ganze Weile gebraucht, bis er dieses Problem aus den komplexeren Problemen der Elektrodynamik so rausgeschält hat, dass man es auf diese Punkte bringen kann. Das ist übrigens eine seiner großen Fähigkeiten gewesen, in so einem komplexen Gewebe von Problemen dann den Kern zu erkennen, wo ist der Grundwiderspruch? Wo ist der Grundkonflikt überhaupt, dass man sich vorstellen kann, dass in wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen solche Widersprüche drin sind. Das ist eine Stärke, die er hatte. Weil man kann es ja alles immer irgendwie hinbiegen. Das kennt man ja auch aus anderen Diskursen. Entweder man versucht, das alles ganz versöhnlich zu machen, und dann ist das alles so eine Soße und alles verträgt sich mit allem, oder man sagt irgendwann, ne, Moment, das ist doch eigentlich widerspricht sich doch. Das kann doch nicht einfach wahr sein so. Und Einstein ist da sozusagen, konnte das durchstechen dann zu diesen Widersprüchen. Auch über viele Gespräche, die er hatte, gibt berühmte Erinnerungen, dass dann gerade ein Gespräch mit seinem Freund Michele Besso, der sonst wirklich nicht der allerklügste und professionellste war, aber der hat ihn dann durch Gespräche so weit gebracht, dass er erkannt hat, Einstein, 1905, das ist ein Problem, wie misst man eigentlich Zeit. Dann ist er nochmal zurückgegangen und hat sich genau überlegt, wie misst man eigentlich Zeiten, wie synchronisiert man Uhren, die an verschiedenen Orten sind, wie synchronisiert man dann wieder Systeme von Uhren, die sich gegeneinander bewegen und hat das alles nochmal neu durchdacht, aber jetzt unter der neuen Voraussetzung, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer die gleiche bleibt. Dann kommt man nämlich zu anderen Raum- und Zeitbegriffen und kommt zu der Erkenntnis, dass wenn ich jetzt eine Uhr in einem fahrenden Zug beobachte, dass die anders läuft als meine Uhr, die ich hier im runden System habe. Und zwar laufen die Uhren genau so anders und auch die Maßstäbe, mit denen ich Längen messe, verhalten sich genau so anders, dass dieses Ergebnis dabei rauskommt, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit immer die gleiche ist. Also Sie sehen, da gibt es auch so eine Umdrehung. Normalerweise würde man ja sagen, ich leg erstmal fest, was Raum und Zeit ist und dann messe ich Geschwindigkeiten, zum Beispiel die Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Aber durch die Erkenntnisse, durch die sich anhäufenden Erkenntnisse in der Elektrodynamik, der Optik, das sind ja sozusagen riesen Erkenntnisgebäude, von denen er ausgegangen ist und die in dem schon genannten Werk von Lorenz dann bereits synthetisiert worden sind, auf das Wesen gebracht worden sind, sieht man, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit offenbar was Besonderes ist. Und Einstein hatte nun den Mut, das Ganze sozusagen vom Kopf auf die Füße zu stellen und zu sagen, jetzt gehe ich mal von dieser Tatsache aus und überlege mir, wir könnten denn Raum- und Zeitbegriffe aussehen, die dieser Tatsache gerecht werden. Und das ist wirklich eine, wenn man so will, kopanikanische Wende des Denkens, weil man jetzt nicht mehr davon ausgeht, dass eine ist gegeben und das andere ist abgeleitet, sondern man dreht es um und man sagt, wie wäre es, wenn ich das andere mal als Prinzip setze?
Was wäre, wenn die Erde sich um die Sonne dreht und die umgekehrt?
Und das hat dann eben alles vereinfacht dargestellt, aber im Wesentlichen, glaube ich, kommt man diesem Vorgang doch nahe, weil sie schlagen die Bücher von Lorenz auf, alles fürchterlich komplex. Sie schauen bei Einstein nach, viel einfacher, die gleichen Formeln, die dann im Wesentlichen diese Verbindung zwischen dem bewegten und dem ruhenden System herstellen, die sogenannten Lorenz-Transformationen, die bleiben im Wesentlichen die gleichen mit dieser ganz unterschiedlichen Interpretation. Aber Einstein fängt dann wirklich an, über so einfache Dinge zu reden wie Uhren und Maßstäbe und die bewegen sich. Also auf dieser Ebene zu denken, die ja eigentlich eine philosophische, eine erkenntnistheoretische Ebene ist und daraus Konsequenzen für die Physik zu ziehen, das war so die eigentliche Leistung 1905. Und da muss man sich vorstellen, das findet dann überraschend schnell an Klang, muss man sagen. Das ist zwar revolutionär gewesen, aber war dann so eine erfolgreiche Systematisierung all dieser Erkenntnisse dieses komplexen Feldes, dass auch Leute wie Plank, die Einstein zunächst mal gar nicht kannten, auch Leute wie Sommerfeld dann, die sind dann auf diesen Zug mit aufgesprungen und haben gesehen, dass das eine sinnvolle Zusammenfassung dieser Probleme war.
Es bestach vor allem durch seine Einfachheit.
So ist es, genau, es bestach durch seine Einfachheit. Aber jetzt kommt sozusagen der nächste überraschende Schritt. Einstein sitzt immer noch am Patentamt, zwei Jahre später, und ist jetzt angefragt worden, sozusagen seinen Stern, der geht so langsam auf. Er ist jetzt von einem Jahrbuch angefragt worden, jetzt noch mal eine Übersicht zu machen über, was muss sich jetzt in der Physik alles verändern, wenn man diese neuen Raum- und Zeitbegriffe berücksichtigt. Und dann setzt er sich hin und schreibt das, was man heute einen Review-Artikel, also einen Übersichtsartikel, nennen würde. Und beschäftigt sich jetzt mit einem Phänomen nach dem anderen. Und kommt auf das Problem der Schwerkraft. Das liegt ganz nah eigentlich, denn nach Newton ist die Schwerkraft ja etwas, was etwa das Planetensystem zusammenhält. Die Sonne zieht die Planeten an, die Planeten ziehen die Sonne an und es entsteht so wie eine magnetische Kraft, die das miteinander verbindet. Und jetzt kann man sich natürlich die Frage stellen, breitet sich diese Kraft instantan auf oder aus oder breitet sie sich mit einer begrenzten Geschwindigkeit aus? Und nach der speziellen Relativitätstheorie darf es eigentlich keine physikalische Wirkung geben, die sich schneller als das Licht ausbreitet.
Warum? Was?
Weil es eine Grenzgeschwindigkeit ist und die ganzen Begriffe von Raum und Zeit so formiert ist, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit sozusagen die Grenzgeschwindigkeit ist. Das ist sozusagen ein ganzes Gerüst.
Okay, also gerade in dieser Theorie steckt schon die Aussage drin, dass das sozusagen die ultimative Geschwindigkeit an sich ist und nicht nur jetzt in Bezug auf Licht.
Nein, nicht nur in Bezug auf Licht, sondern auch in Bezug auf andere Phänomene. Das ist ja die Relativitätstheorie, die spezielle. Er hat ja im Grunde aus diesem Problem der Elektrodynamik ein kinematisches Problem gemacht. Das heißt ein Problem von Raum und Zeit. Also das ist ja die andere Perspektive, auch das, was Einstein 1905 gemacht hat. Er hat dieses Spezialproblem, äther, bewegt er sich oder nicht, wie verhalten sich die elektromagnetischen Kräfte usw. rausgenommen aus dieser speziellen Domäne der Physik und sozusagen zu einem neuen Rahmen von Raum und Zeit erweitert. Und zu diesem neuen Rahmen von Raum und Zeit gehörte auch, dass sich keine physikalische Wirkung schneller als das Licht ausbreiten darf. Das war jetzt der Hintergrund für seinen Übersichtsartikel. Jetzt mal die ganze Physik durchzuchecken, wie muss ich das umformulieren? Da die Lichtgeschwindigkeit eine sehr große Geschwindigkeit ist, waren die Anpassungen im Grunde nicht so schwierig, weil die uns im Alltag praktisch nicht betreffen. Also wir müssen jetzt unsere Uhren, wenn ich gleich wieder ins Auto steige, nicht umstellen, damit wir noch Verabredungen treffen können, weil uns das einfach nicht betrifft, weil wir uns zu langsam bewegen. Das gilt einfach für fast alle Effekte, die wir so im Alltag beobachten. Nicht für alle, aber für fast alle. Und dann war Einstein jetzt damit beschäftigt, so eine Art Aufräumarbeit zu leisten. Und da kam ihm das Problem der Schwerkraft unter. Und die Frage, was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel an der Sonne wackeln würde, wann würde der Planet die Wirkung spüren? Würde er sie instantan, ohne Zeitverzögerung spüren? Oder würde diese Wirkung sich auch mit maximaler Lichtgeschwindigkeit ausbreiten? Das ist eine aus der Perspektive dieser neuen Raumzeitlehre spezielle Relativitätstheorie, naheliegende Frage. Und in vielen Fällen hatten solche naheliegenden Fragen auch naheliegende Antworten. Nur in dem Falle ließ es sich schwer machen.
Also die Gravitation war sozusagen überhaupt nicht Teil der speziellen Relativitätstheorie. Das war dann auch komplett außen vor.
Einerseits außen vor, aber andererseits war das halt eine Raumzeitlehre, die spezielle Relativitätstheorie. Insofern sollte alles in sie reinpassen, eben auch die Gravitation. Nun musste Einstein, und das hatten auch andere unabhängig von ihm gesehen, eigentlich musste man jetzt ein neues Newton-Schiss-Gravitationsgesetz formulieren, das dieser Tatsache Rechnung trägt. Und das erwies sich als sehr viel schwieriger und problematischer, als Einstein das vermutet hatte. Und dann kommt wieder der Punkt, ja, passt man das an? Das kann man nämlich auch machen, sodass man das jetzt doch irgendwie so dreht und tüftelt, dass es anpasst. Aber da muss man einen Preis dafür bezahlen. Und der Preis, den man dafür bezahlen muss, ist das andere einfache Prinzipien der klassischen Physik, wie die Tatsache, dass alle Körper gleich schnell fallen, die würden dann nicht mehr so ohne weiteres gelten. Und Einstein hat dann so ein Gedankenexperiment angestellt, dass ein Körper, der sich horizontal bewegt, kann sich ja vorstellen, ein Körper fällt runter, ein anderer fällt auch runter, aber gleichzeitig bewegt er sich horizontal, dass die nicht mehr gleichzeitig ankommen. Und das hat ihn verblüfft. Und das hat ihn dazu geführt, das Raumzeitkonzept, das er eben erst aufgestellt hatte, zwei Jahre früher, noch mal fundamental zu verändern.
Wo er jetzt von allen bejubelt wurde als super, tolle Lösung. Jetzt haben wir das endlich mal klar geregelt. Zwei Jahre später hat das schon wieder in Frage geschaut.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Und zwar wegen eines Problems, das erst mal experimentell überhaupt irrelevant war. Das ist ein ganz minimaler Effekt, den konnte man nicht mal messen. Damit hätte man sich auch zufrieden geben können.
Mit dieser Schrägbewegung. Wie konnte er das überhaupt beobachten?
Er konnte es nicht beobachten, das kann man erschließen. Das kann man mit einem Gedankenexperiment erschließen, dass das eine Konsequenz der speziellen Relativitätstheorie angewandt auf die Fallbewegung sein muss. Und dann kann man sagen, das können wir mal überprüfen, vielleicht ist das so, wäre interessant. Aber Einstein hat eine andere Haltung eingenommen. Er hat gesagt, nee, das hat doch schon Galilee, Schieferturm von Pisa und so weiter, alle Körper fallen schnell, das ist so ein Grundprinzip. Das kann gar nicht anders sein. Und was hat er sich wieder genau diese Umdrehung gewahrt? Wie würde denn eine Physik aussehen, bei der das Grundprinzip trotz spezieller Relativitätstheorie erhalten bleibt? Also wie muss ich eine Theorie bauen, in der erstens gilt, die Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist immer konstant und ist eine Grenzgeschwindigkeit. Und zweitens, es gibt so etwas wie die Universalität der Fallbewegung. Und das wurde 1907 immer noch am Patentamt der Ausgangspunkt für was dann später, acht Jahre später, die Allgemeine Relativitätstheorie geworden ist. Und er hat dann so ein berühmtes Gedankenexperiment, der war ja groß, was heißt Gedankenexperiment? Gedankenexperiment heißt ja nur, dass man die Konsequenzen von so einer Theorie auslotet, auch mit Vorstellungen, die man aus anderen Erfahrungen, aus den Alltagserfahrungen zum Beispiel, nimmt. Und da hat er sich überlegt, wie ist das, wenn ich jetzt hier aus dem dritten Stock springen würde, oder ich würde einen Dachdecker sehen, der gerade abgesprungen ist, und der würde auch so ein Fallexperiment machen. Der würde ja, wenn das richtig ist, dass alle Körper gleich schnell fallen, der würde ja plötzlich gar keine Gravitationskraft momentan mehr spüren und würde einfach so einen Ball, den er gerade hat fallen lassen, vor sich her schweben sehen. Das heißt, man könnte sich überlegen, ob man das Relativitätsprinzip, das bis dahin ja nur diese gleichförmigen Bewegungen erfasst hat, auch auf beschleunigte Bewegungen ausdehnt und sich vorstellt, dass man die Gravitation gewissermaßen kompensieren kann, indem man beschleunigte Bewegungen in die Betrachtung mit einbezieht. Also in einem beschleunigten, in einem fallenden Labor wäre es kurzfristig, bis man unten aufgnallt natürlich, so als würden überhaupt keine Schwerkräfte wirksam sein. Umgekehrt kann man sich vorstellen, da sind wir schon fast bei der Raumfahrt, man stellt sich jetzt weit ab von irgendwelchen schwere Feldern eine Rakete vor, so eine Art Black Box, die jetzt plötzlich beschleunigt wird. Da drin ist ein Beobachter und der lässt jetzt auch was fallen. Und kann jetzt, hat die Freiheit, die dann auftretenden Beschleunigungskräfte zu interpretieren als Schwerkräfte. Wenn die gleichmäßig sind, kann er sich vorstellen, eigentlich steht er auf einem Planeten und erlegt der schwere Kraft, er lässt jetzt was runterfallen, das landet auf dem Boden. Und dann kommt natürlich der Punkt, das würde ja genauso landen, wie die Universalität des Falls das vorschreibt. Nämlich, da das jetzt sozusagen ein rein kinematischer Effekt ist, diese Beschleunigung würden alle Körper dann gleich schnell auf den Boden ankommen. Das heißt, das leuchtete ihm dann ein, dass es da so ein Wechselspiel zwischen den Trägheits-, den Beschleunigungskräften gibt und den Schwerekräften. Und das war in der klassischen Physik immer schon so ein bisschen ein Problem, weil sie haben eigentlich zwei Massebegriffe in der klassischen Physik. Sie haben einen Begriff von schwerer Masse, die ist dafür verantwortlich, dass die Körper sich anziehen. Ähnlich wie die elektrische Ladung bewirkt, dass Körper sich elektrisch anziehen. Und dann gibt es die Trägermasse, die dafür sorgt, dass Körper sich Beschleunigungen widersetzen. Also die Kraft, die man etwa spürt, wenn man sozusagen ein Körper an der Schnur, so ein Pendel, rumschwingt, dann merkt man, da gibt es eine Zentrifugalkraft, die man dann dadurch erklärt in der Klassik und Physik, dass der Körper eigentlich geradeaus weiterfliegen will, aber durch die Schnur daran gehindert wird. Dass diese Kraft ist eigentlich eine Trägheitskraft, weil die Masse, die will eigentlich auf ihrem Kurs bleiben. Auch wenn man im Flugzeug sozusagen die Beschleunigungskräfte spürt, das ist eigentlich, weil man im Zustand der Ruhe oder gleichformigen Bewegungen verharren will. Das ist das Newtonische Trägheitsgesetz. Und dann passiert irgendwas, was einen davon abbringt. Das spürt man dann als Trägheitskraft. Und dass die beiden genau gleich sind, was dann eben die Ursache dafür ist, dass alle Körper gleich schnell fallen. Warum fällt ein Körper aus Blei und ein Körper aus Holz im Vakuum? Die Astronauten haben auf dem Mond solche Experimente gemacht, weil da die Luft nicht stört. Warum fallen die gleich schnell runter? Weil einerseits natürlich hat ein Körper aus Blei, der das gleiche Volumen hat wie ein Körper aus Holz, natürlich die größere Anziehungskraft und müsste eigentlich schneller fallen. Aber er hat eben auch die größere Trägheitsmasse. Und insofern ist auch nicht nur die Beschleunigung größer, sondern auch die Verzögerung. Und zwar genauso, dass er gleich schnell fällt wie jeder andere Körper. Also das, was da sozusagen drückt oder zieht, die schwere Masse ist genauso wirksam wie das, was da bremst und verzögert, die Trägermasse. Und das schien in der klassischen Physik ein reiner Zufall zu sein. Dass diese beiden Kräfte, dass diese beiden Effekte sich genau ausgleichen. Dass die Trägermasse immer genau gleich der schweren Masse ist. Und das ist exakt so. Das hat man sozusagen mit Präzisionsexperimenten auch schon in Einsteins Zeit. Alles mögliche. Oder der berühmte ungarische Physiker hat da Experimente zugemacht. Also das ist erstaunlich präzise der Fall. Und Einstein hat da jetzt rausgeschlossen, wie wäre es denn, wenn ich annehmen würde, dass die sogenannten Trägheitskräfte und die schweren Kräfte eigentlich nur zwei Seiten derselben Medaille sind. Und dieses Beispiel von dem fallenden Dachdecker, das zeigt ja im Grunde, dass ich durch Beschleunigung zeitweise die schwere Kraft aufheben kann. Und das ist ja so eine andere Darstellung, genau dieses Kompensationseffekt ist. Warum spüre ich das nicht? Warum fühle ich mich wie im freien Fall, als wenn ich schwerelos wäre? Weil genau diese Beschleunigungskräfte und die Schwerkraft sich ausheben. Das ist aber nur eine mögliche Kombination dieser beiden Kräfte. Und das war sozusagen die Grundidee. Und Einstein hat das in Analogie gesehen zur Verbindung von elektrischen und magnetischen Kräften in der elektromagnetischen Theorie. Da hat man ja auch zunächst isoliert voneinander die Anziehungskräfte von kleinen statischen Anziehungskräften, wenn man so will, von elektrisch geladenen Körpern. Dann auf der anderen Seite die Magnetkraft. Scheint was Verschiedenes zu sein. Aber im Laufe des 19. Jahrhunderts, dann durch Faraday und Maxwell, hat man erkannt, dass das eigentlich zwei Seiten des selben elektromagnetischen Feldes sind. Und Einstein kannte das natürlich extrem gut, diesen Bereich Elektrodynamik. Und hat jetzt per Analogie geschlossen, dass Gravitation und Trägheit eigentlich ebenso zusammengehören. Und zwei Aspekte des selben umfassenden, wir nennen es nicht so, aber so müsste man es vielleicht nennen, Gravito-Inertial-Felds wären. Und dann sind wir schon gleich beim nächsten Schritt, nachdem er diese Einsichten hatte. Also ich wiederhole mal, er stieß erst mal auf die Schwierigkeit, die Gravitation in die spezielle Relativitätstheorie einzubauen, hat dann damit so ein bisschen rumgespielt und ist auf die Frage gekommen, wie verhält sich eigentlich die Trägheitskraft zur Schwerekraft? Hat dann gesehen, dass es sinnvoll wäre, die in eine einheitliche Theorie zu überführen, eine Theorie des elektromagnetischen, sondern des gravito-inertialen Fels. Und dann war bei dem Problem, da muss ich jetzt so eine Feldtheorie machen, wie für die Elektrodynamik.
Das war jetzt aber alles noch im Rahmen seiner Aufgabe, diesen Artikel zu schreiben, sozusagen.
Ja, das war der Ausgangspunkt. Er hat bereits 1907 dann auch erste Konsequenzen daraus gezogen, den man kann sich zum Beispiel vorstellen, wenn man in so einem beschleunigten Kasten sitzt, der jetzt mal das schwere Feld simulieren soll, aufgrund der darin wirkenden Trägheitskräfte. Und man schickt jetzt so einen Lichtstrahl durch diesen beschleunigten Kasten. Da kommt dann auf der einen Seite so ein kleines Löchlein raus, trifft dann aber nicht genau am gegenüberliegenden Ende auf die Wand, sondern etwas tiefer, etwas schräg runter. Und wenn man das jetzt wieder übersetzt, das war jetzt der Fall der Beschleunigung, aber die Beschleunigung entspricht der Schwerkraft, dann kann man daraus folgern, dass in der Schwerkraft das Licht einer Ablenkung unterworfen ist. Weil die Schwerkraft müsste ja genauso wirken wegen der Äquivalenz von Schwerkraft und Beschleunigungskräften wie in dem Falle diese Beschleunigungssituation. Und Einstein konnte also 1907 bereits vorhersagen, dass sich Licht im schwere Feld krümmen würde. Er hat noch weitere Vorhersagen daraus geschlossen. Eigentlich alle sogenannten klassischen Vorhersagen der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie waren ihm bereits 1907 klar. Also da gibt es noch den Effekt einer Rotverschiebung. Und es gibt den Effekt, dass es, weil es ja die newtonsche Gravitationskraft ein bisschen ändert, eine kleine Drehung der Planetenbahn geben sollte. Das war ein Effekt, der schon bekannt war, den man natürlich nicht sicher war, wie man ihr erklären konnte. Eventuell gab es ja unbekannte Planeten, die dann noch so einen Effekt haben könnten durch die Störwirkungen der Planeten untereinander. Aber der Effekt war eben auch seit dem 19. Jahrhundert schon bekannt. Und Einstein hat gleich in 1907 vermutet, vielleicht, wenn man diese Theorie ausbaut, kann man den damit erklären. Aber erst mal muss er die Theorie ausstellen. Aber ich finde das immer so spannend, weil er hatte sozusagen 1907 schon das ganze Gerüst für diese Theorie vor sich liegen. Ohne die Theorie selbst überhaupt zu kennen. Und da hat er acht Jahre gebraucht, bis er dann aus diesen Einsichten die Theorie selber ausbauen konnte. Und 1915, also wirklich acht Jahre später, hat er dann erst die fertige Theorie veröffentlichen können. Nach vielen Versuchen, die dann auch gescheitert sind, nach Irrungen und Wirrungen, ist es ihm dann gelungen, das aufzustellen, was wir heute als allgemeine Relativitätstheorie bezeichnen. Und mehr als diese paar, und übrigens von diesen drei Effekten, die ich genannt habe, also diese Lichtablenkung im Schwerefeld, die Rotverschiebung durchs Gravitationsfeld und diese kleine Drehung der Bahn, der Planeten, die nur bei Merkur wirklich beobachtbar war, hatte er 1915 nur einen Effekt, den er wirklich kannte. Weil die anderen beiden Effekte, die waren zunächst mal nicht bekannt. 1919 wurde dann die Lichtablenkung bestätigt, aber das war dann eben auch vier Jahre später noch. Als er seine Theorie veröffentlichte, hat er nur den einzigen Effekt, der ihm einen Hinweis gab, dass diese Theorie die richtige ist, nämlich diese Planetendrehung.
Was ist denn das für eine Drehung? Wovon reden wir denn jetzt? Wir reden von so einem Schlingerkurs.
Die Bahn selber ist ja eine Ellipse. Und diese Ellipse hat einen Punkt, wo sich der Sonne am nächsten liegt. Das ist das Perihel. Und dieses Perihel selber dreht sich dann um die Sonne.
Dreht sich sozusagen um die Sonne mit und liegt dann immer woanders.
Und liegt dann immer woanders. Und eigentlich ist das ein Effekt, der weitgehend bereits auf die Störung der anderen Planeten zurückzuführen ist. Der nicht auftreten würde, wenn man nur zwei Massenpunkte hätte. Aber das ist ja ein Viehkörperproblem. Die anderen Planeten wirken ja auch mit. Aber ein ganz kleiner Anteil dieser Drehung war bis dahin nicht erklärbar. Und da haben die Leute zunächst mal nach einem inneren Planeten Vulkanen noch gesucht. Und natürlich, man kannte den interplanetaren Raum halt nicht besonders gut. Also wer weiß, was sich da noch an nicht sichtbarer Materie herumtrieb. Gab es auch Vermutungen, die diesen Effekt hätten verursachen können.
Aber was genau jetzt in seiner Betrachtung hat sozusagen dann diese Rechnung aufgelöst bekommen?
Die leichte Veränderung der Newtonischen Schwerkraft, die dann letztendlich so wirkt wie eine Störung der Newtonischen Theorie.
Das hat aber auch dann auch alles ausgerechnet.
Das musste er und hat er ausgerechnet. Und interessanterweise zunächst einmal aufgrund einer Vorläufertheorie. Er hat dann 1913 zusammen mit diesem Mathematiker-Freund Marcel Grossmann eine vorläufige Theorie aufgestellt. Die nannte er dann selber zunächst auch mal Entwurftheorie. Und dann hat er mit einem anderen Freund wiederum, das sind alles diese Freunde, die in der Umgebung haben, hat er sich hingesetzt und das seitenweise durchgerechnet. Wir sind in der glücklichen Lage, dass wir die Manuskripte dazu noch haben. Hat er sozusagen systematisch alles durchgesetzt. Es kam leider ein zu kleines Ergebnis raus, dass so etwas mehr als ein Drittel unterhalb des erwarteten Wertes lag. Und er hat das auch einfach in der Schublade verschwinden lassen und auch nie darüber geredet. Und an der Theorie, an derselben Theorie weitergemacht, hat sich auch nicht weiter davon stören lassen. Er war so von den Grundprinzipien überzeugt, dass er dann einfach weitergemacht hat. Aber dann ist er durch andere Probleme später von dieser Entwurftheorie auf die endgültige allgemeine Relativitätstheorie gekommen. Und dann hat er wieder die Schublade aufgemacht, hat diese Rechnung rausgenommen und sie ruckzuck angepasst an die endgültige Theorie. Und alle Leute, die ihn, ich sage mal, nicht ganz zu unrecht für keinen besonders begabten Mathematiker hielten, die hat er natürlich verblüfft, weil er innerhalb von Tagen dieses komplizierte Ergebnis ausrechnen konnte.
Weil er die Arbeit schon geleistet hatte.
Weil er es im Grunde schon hatte in der Schublade.
Er war kein guter Mathematiker?
Also, Einstein war, wenn Sie das mal vergleichen, auch mit Leuten, die zum Teil an seine Konkurrenten geworden sind, wie David Hilbert, einer der größten Mathematiker des 20. Jahrhunderts. Auch sein eigener Freund, Marcel Grossmann, musste ihm helfen beim Auffinden der mathematischen Sprache für diese Theorie. Einstein hatte als Student die entsprechenden Vorlesungen geschwänzt. Der ist überhaupt nur durchgekommen, weil er die Mathematikhefte seines Freundes Marcel Grossmann zur Vorbereitung der Examen nutzen konnte. Als er diese Idee hatte, dass diese Neue, darüber haben wir glaube ich noch gar nicht gesprochen, dass diese Vereinheitlichung von Trägheits- und Gravitationskraft ein völlig neues Konzept von Raum und Zeit erforderte, jetzt wiederum ein neues Konzept von Raum und Zeit, bei dem Raum und Zeit gekrümmt sind, und zwar durch den Effekt der Massen im Weltraum gekrümmt sind. Dafür braucht man eine Sprache, nämlich die der nicht euklidischen Geometrie. Die kannte Einstein ansatzweise, aber nicht in ihren technischen Feinheiten. Also er hatte dann irgendwann den Gedanken, weil die erste Frage, die sich dann stellt ist, ja, okay, wenn das alles so ist mit der Trägheits- und der Gravitationskraft, ja, wie sieht dann so eine Feldtheorie aus? Und so eine Feldtheorie, die besteht immer aus zwei Teilen. Da muss ich einmal sagen, was ist denn die Wirkung der Quellen auf das Feld, wie beeinflussen Massen die Umgebung, sodass sich das Feld entsprechend ändert, und wie wirkt dann dieses Feld auf die Bewegung der Massen wieder zurück? Das ist eine Feldtheorie. Auch die elektromagnetische Feldtheorie sieht so aus. Ich hab die elektrischen Massen, die elektrischen Ladung, und ich hab die Ströme, die machen ein elektromagnetisches Feld. Und das elektromagnetische Feld schreibt mir dann wiederum vor, wie sich dann die Ladungen bewegen müssen. Das ist das Wesen so einer Theorie. Und das Gleiche muss da Einstein für diese Gravitationstheorie nur aufstellen. Und sagen, wie sieht jetzt die Feldgleichung aus, die sagt, wie eine Masse ein Feld erzeugt. Und wie sieht dann die Bewegungsgleichung aus, die mir sagt, wie bewegt sich dann so eine Masse in diesem Feld. Das ist ganz abstrakt jetzt erstmal. Aber er kam dann relativ bald, schon 1912 kam er zu dem Ergebnis, den einen Teil, diese Bewegungsgleichung, den kann ich sehr schnell lösen, wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass das Feld den Raum krümmt. Raum und Zeit genauer gesagt. Dann ist nämlich die Bewegung einer Masse in dieser Krümmung von Raum und Zeit so wie die Bewegung eines Teilchens auf einer gekrümmten Oberfläche, das einfach den am wenigsten gekrümmten Weg durch diese gekrümmte Raumzeit findet. Also das nennt man dann Geodate, das ist sozusagen die Idee. Man findet eine Entsprechung zu den geraden Linien auf den Ebenen. Auch auf gekrümmten Flächen kennen wir alle von unserer Erdkugel her. Wir müssen uns auf der Kugeloberfläche bewegen. Also können wir keine gerade Linie durch die Erde ziehen, sondern bewegen uns auf sogenannten Großkreisen. Das sind die besten Entsprechungen, die wir haben zu den geraden Linien auf einer gekrümmten Fläche. Wenn man jetzt annimmt, dass Raum und Zeit gekrümmt sind, kann man auch da die sozusagen gradesten Linien auswählen. Das sind diese sogenannten Geodaten. Und das sind dann die Linien, auf denen sich Körper bewegen, die nur sich selber bzw. der Schwerkraft und der Trägheit unterworfen sind. Auf die keine anderen Kräfte wirken. Das löst im Grunde für ihn das Problem der Bewegungsgleichung. Das hat er schon sehr früh gelöst. Und das Problem der Feldgleichung hat noch mehr Zeit in Anspruch genommen. Aber auf diese Weise hatte er schon mal sozusagen einen wesentlichen Teil der Theorie. Und die Mathematik, um das im Einzelnen auszubestabieren, die kannte er nicht. Er war dann zeitweise in Prag. Als Professor kam er dann zurück nach Zürich und hat sich dann an seinen Freund Grossmann gewandt und sagt Grossmann, ich werd verrückt, ich kann das nicht, hilf mir. Du bist der Mathematiker. Und wir haben die Notizbücher. Und da kann man sehr deutlich sehen, der Einstein fängt an, also fast klippschulartig, mit diesen einfachen Formeln über gekrümmte Flächen. Genauso wie ich es jetzt gerade versucht habe zu erläutern, so zeichnete er sich dann so eine Linie auf einer gekrümmten Fläche und überlegt sich, ja, da könnte sich das bewegen. Aber weiter erreichte seine Mathematik nicht. Das war so der Zustand, den schon Gauss erreicht hatte. Das kannte er noch. Und dann sieht man, plötzlich taucht der Name Grossmann in diesen Notizbüchern aus. Und neben Grossmann steht dann der Sonat Riemann-Tensor und die ganze komplizierte Mathematik, die inzwischen dieses Niveau erreicht hatte. Und das liefert Einstein dann die Sprache, um seine Theorie zu formulieren. Aber das ist eben keine lineare Fortschrittsentwicklung gewesen, sondern das ist ein Hin und Her gewesen. Weil Einstein musste sich diese Sprache aneignen. Er musste versuchen, seine physikalischen Intuitionen in dieser Sprache auszudrücken. Das ging nicht ohne Weiteres. Musste also auch lernen, wiederum aus dieser neuen Sprache seine physikalischen Intuitionen zu verändern. Und in diesem Hin und Her zwischen Mathematik und Physik hat sich dann schließlich acht Jahre lang die Allgemeine Relativitätstheorie entwickelt.
Die dann 2015 vorgestellt wurde. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte er ja auch schon Gehör. Also in den zehn Jahren seit der Veröffentlichung der speziellen Relativitätstheorie.
Nicht unbedingt. Der hat natürlich seine wissenschaftliche Karriere gemacht. Am 19.15., am 25. November, war er inzwischen nach Berlin berufen worden. Aber er ist nicht wegen der Relativitätstheorie nach Berlin berufen worden. Er ist berufen worden, weil er andere Arbeiten gemacht hat, die Berliner Physiker und Chemiker interessiert haben. Nämlich zum Zustand der Materie, zum Zustand der Strahlung. Also Einstein wurde nach Berlin gerufen, weil man sich von ihm erhoffte, dass er die Quantentheorie weiterentwickeln würde. Weil die hatte eine unmittelbare Relevanz für Chemie, für Festkörper, Physik und so weiter. Stattdessen hat er sein Hobbyhorst weiter geritten. Diese Fragen von Raum und Zeit und so. Das hat im Grunde keinen Menschen interessiert.
Also trotz der speziellen Relativitätstheorie, die ja jetzt nicht komplett unbemerkt veröffentlicht wurde, ist niemand eingestiegen auf diese Gedankenwelt und hat gesagt, da denke ich jetzt auch mal drüber nach.
Es gab schon einige. Es gab wiederum eine Handvoll etwa von Leuten, die darauf eingestiegen sind und auch mit Einstein diskutiert haben. Aber die berühmten Leute, die ihn dann auch nach Berlin berufen haben, also auch Leute wie Planck oder von Laue und andere, die haben eigentlich nichts davon gehalten. Und das kann man verstehen, weil die spezielle Relativitätstheorie hat erstmal ein großes Problem gelöst, was alle Leute hatten, nämlich wie geht man mit dieser Elektrodynamik bewegter Körper um. Und selbst wenn das jetzt im Alltag keine Konsequenzen hatte, man hatte Kathodenröhren, man hatte lauter Experimente, in denen sich Teilchen schon fast lichtschnell bewegten. Das hatte deutliche experimentelle Konsequenzen. Wir wollen nicht vergessen, Einstein hat dann im Folge der, noch 1905 im Nachdenken über die spezielle Relativitätstheorie seine berühmte Formel E gleich mc² aufgestellt. Equivalenz von Masse und Energie. Man sah schon sehr früh, dass das sozusagen auch bedeutende Anwendungen haben konnte oder jedenfalls eine Relevanz haben konnte. Während dieses Nachdenken darüber, ob Körper nun gleich schnell fallen oder nicht gleich schnell fallen und was Trägheit und Gravitation, ja Trägheit und Gravitation, da hat schon Leibniz darüber nachgedacht. Und so, warum sollte da jetzt was Neues bei rauskommen? Man hatte ja überhaupt keine neue Empirie. Also das haben sie im Grunde und dann wurde diese Theorie durch das, was wir gerade besprochen haben, nämlich durch diese komplexe Mathematik beliebig kompliziert. Das war ja auch eine Mathematik, die den damaligen Physikern überhaupt nicht geläufig waren. Ein paar spezialisierte Mathematiker kannten das. Das wirkte also sehr abgehoben. Und es hatte eigentlich keine Konsequenzen. Okay, dieses Merkur-Ding. Aber wer wusste schon, was sonst noch im Raume war, was das hätte erklären können.
Das heißt, es war an sich alles schlüssig, aber die Dimension der Arbeit war nicht bekannt. Und auch nach der Veröffentlichung der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie. Es gab halt ein paar Vorhersagen. Und dann musste es erst zu dieser Sonnenfinsternis kommen.
Ja, es gab ein paar Spezialisten, die da mitgewirkt haben und das mathematisch interessant fanden und das so ein bisschen ausgebügelt haben, das Ganze. Und hat Einstein auch Bücher geschrieben darüber, hat sozusagen dann nochmal einen großen Review-Artikel geschrieben. Also der hatte schon alles ein bisschen weiterbewegt. Aber wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen größer schaut, dann ist es völlig richtig, was Sie sagen, erstens mit der Sonnenfinsternis. Nehmen Sie den berühmten Physiker wie Max von Lauer, auch Nobelpreisträger und so weiter, ein Freund von Einstein, der hat einem anderen Kollegen geschrieben, hat gesagt, na ich hoffe, wenn das erstmal jetzt zu dieser Sonnenfinsternis-Beobachtung kommt, dann ist der Spuk bald vorüber.
Dann wird man feststellen, dass er sich die ganze Zeit nur mit irgendwelchen Grillen beschäftigt.
So ist es. Und dann war es aber anders. Dann ist es anders gekommen und dann hat die Theorie natürlich eine große Prominenz erlangt. War dann auch umstritten. Das fiel dann auch in so eine Nachkriegs-Modernisierungsdebatte, Kulturkritik.
Jetzt kann man noch mal ganz kurz aufschlüsseln, was da konkret passiert ist. Also es gab ein Sonnenfinsternis, damit war quasi die Sonne beobachtbar. Und wenn ich jetzt richtig erinnere, war ein Objekt, was im Prinzip, wenn man jetzt eine reine geometrische Achse von der Erde zu diesem Objekt, also zu einem Stern gezogen hat, hinter der Sonne und hätte sozusagen eigentlich nicht sichtbar...
Ja, das ist sozusagen der Extremfall. Das ist zwar richtig, aber das wäre der Extremfall.
Also man hatte eine bestimmte Position im Sinn, wo es eigentlich hätte sichtbar sein müssen, war aber anders. Weil die Sonne den Raum so gekrümmt hat, dass das Licht einfach anders lief und von daher anders aussah. Und damit war im Prinzip die Vorhersage der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie an der Stelle zumindest vollständig genauso erfüllt, wie eben von Einstein festgelegt.
Und man wusste, dass man ja den gleichen Sternenhimmel in einer anderen Jahreszeit ohne die Sonne fotografieren und wusste also genau, wie die Sterne stehen sollten. Und nun konnte man ihn bei einer Sonnenfinsternis auch in Präsenz der Sonne, die diese Krümmungen verursacht, beobachten und konnte einfach diese Fotoplatten gegeneinander halten und nun sehen, dass sich da leichte Positionsverschiebungen ergaben. Und die waren genauso wie die Theorie, die es vorher gesagt hat, innerhalb der Messgenauigkeit. Und das war schon ein Präzisionsexperiment an der Grenze des Machbaren in der Zeit. Aber auch sozusagen ein winziger Effekt. Zunächst mal und hat, ich glaube, eher aufgrund kultureller Umstände, also zeitgeschichtlicher Umstände, Nachkriegszeit und so weiter, dann zu dieser erheblichen Berühmtheit von Einstein gefunden.
Wie lange hat das dann gedauert, bis der Wahnsinn dann losbrach? War das wirklich so von heute auf morgen?
Ja, von heute auf morgen.
Also da hat er sozusagen die moderne Telekommunikations- und Medienlandschaft auch geliefert.
Ja, absolut. Das war gleich eine Weltsensation. Kann man so sagen. Einstein kam dann auf die Titelbilder der Illustrierten. Das war wirklich, da war wirklich was los. Ja, und das hat aber für die Physik zunächst mal, also dann gibt es plötzlich jetzt wirklich eine Trennung der Entwicklung, weil auf der einen Seite gibt es dieses populäre Image von Einstein, auch die philosophische und populärwissenschaftliche und zum Teil polemische Diskussion. Und dann auf der anderen Seite die wissenschaftliche Weiterentwicklung der Theorie. Und die wissenschaftliche Weiterentwicklung hing zunächst mal sehr stark an auch dieser anderen Frage, die wir kurz schon berührt hatten, nämlich der Frage, wie lässt sich denn nun diese Theorie auf den Kosmos als Ganzes anwenden? Denn wenn der Kosmos gekrümmt sein soll, was heißt denn das jetzt für den Kosmos als Ganzes? Newton hatte sich im Grunde einen unendlichen absoluten Raum vorgestellt. Aber was bedeutet das jetzt? Außerdem hatte Einstein ja die Vorstellung, dass Trägheit und Schwerkraft zusammenhängen und er hatte darüber hinaus noch die Erwartung, dass ebenso wie die Gravitationskräfte von Massen verursacht sind, so sollen auch die Trägheitskräfte von Massen verursacht werden. Und wie kann man das jetzt nun zu einem konsistenten Weltmodell ausbauen? Und er hat dann 1917 eine Arbeit vorgelegt, wo er versucht hat, sozusagen mal einen Gesamtentwurf zu machen eines solchen Weltmodells, und das war ein statischer Kosmos gewesen. Darüber hatten wir schon kurz gesprochen. Und dieser statische Kosmos erfüllte Einsteins Erwartungen nur dann, wenn man an den Gleichungen noch mal eine leichte Veränderung vornahm und das sogenannte kosmologische Glied in diese Gleichung einfügte. Also die berühmte kosmologische Konstante, die auch heute wieder stark diskutiert wird, die ist eigentlich zustande gekommen als, und das kann man wirklich nachweisen, die ist zustande gekommen als Antwort auf das Problem, wie kriege ich jetzt vor dem Hintergrund dieser neuen Theorie ein Weltmodell hin, das statisch ist und das mir die Trägheit so erklärt, wie ich mir das möchte? Wir haben übrigens interessanterweise, das zeigt ein bisschen, wie Wissenschaftsgeschichte arbeitet, einige der ersten Rechnungen für diese Theorie auf der Rückseite eines Briefes gefunden, eines Briefentwurfes, den Einstein geschrieben hat an den damaligen österreichischen Kaiser, an den er nämlich einen Gnadengesuch richtete für seinen Physikerfreund Friedrich Adler, Ein Einsteins, der inzwischen den österreichischen Premierminister Stürk aus Protest gegen den ersten Weltkrieg erschossen hatte und jetzt in österreichischen Gefängnis war und zum Tode verurteilt werden sollte und Einstein schrieb also ein Gnadengesuch, das aus anderen Gründen, weil man ihn zunächst für unzurechnungsfähig erklären wollte und so weiter und so weiter, komplizierte Geschichte, hat den nicht abgeschrieben. Auf der Rückseite finden sich die ersten Rechnungen zu diesem kosmologischen Modell. Da hat man also beides, den politischen Einstein und den kosmologischen Einstein in einem Brief.
Aber der kosmologische Einstein ist jetzt an dieser Stelle im Prinzip jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen Opfer seines eigenen Ethers geworden, dass er halt einfach eine Annahme gemacht hat, dass eben das Universum wohl statisch irgendwie ist.
So ist es ja, man muss ihm nur zugute halten, er wusste halt relativ wenig, weil man damals relativ wenig wusste über den Aufbau des Universums. Aber dann kommen jetzt sehr schnell andere Leute ins Spiel, zum Beispiel der holländische Astronom De Sitter, mit dem er dann eine Korrespondenz angefangen hatte und der klärte ihn so darüber auf, dass es da noch ein paar andere Probleme gibt, hat dann auch selber so ein Weltmodell vorgestellt. Und inzwischen liefen in Amerika, in Kalifornien, die ersten großen Beobachtungsprogramme der Galaxien an, oder dessen, was wir heute als Galaxien verstehen. Und der amerikanische Astronomen Hubble kam dann so im Laufe der 20er, Ende der 20er, Anfang der 30er Jahre darauf, dass sich das Universum tatsächlich ausdehnt. Und das erforderte natürlich ganz andere Lösungen von Einsteins Gleichungen. Und die gab es auch schon. Die hatten andere, unabhängig von Einstein, schon vorschlagen. Der russische Mathematiker Alexander Friedmann zum Beispiel hatte gezeigt, dass es solche expandierenden Lösungen gab schon Anfang der 20er Jahre. Einstein hat es zunächst für einen Fehler gehalten, dann konnte man ihm nachweisen, dass es kein Fehler war, dann hat er gesagt, okay, es ist kein Fehler, ist aber irrelevant. Und dann kam der Priester Georges Lemaître, aber auch ein hervorragender Kosmologe und Physiker an und hat diese Weltmodelle weiter ausgewirkt. Einstein hat es einfach nicht ernst genommen. Aber dann gab es eben die Beobachtungen aus Kalifornien von Hubble, die gezeigt haben, es gibt so eine Rotverschiebung, die man am besten dadurch erklären kann, dass sich das Universum allmählich ausdehnt und zwar gleichmäßig ausdehnt. Und das war genau im Sinne dieser dynamischen Lösung von Einsteins Gleichung, wie sie Friedman und Lemaître schon vorgelegt hatten. Und das hat das angefangen, das Bild unseres Universums radikal zu verändern. Das ist eben einfach ein sehr viel stärker dynamisches und nicht statisches Universum, in dem wir leben. Und das kann die Relativitätstheorie eben sehr gut beschreiben. Bloß Einstein wollte es zunächst mal nicht wahrhaben. Das hat er aber dann eingesehen. Andere Sachen hat er nicht eingesehen. Also man kam auch sehr schnell auf das Problem, dass es da sogenannte Singularitäten gibt. Also das, was wir dann später als schwarze Löcher bezeichnen, ist ein Ausdruck, der geht auf die 60er Jahre erst zurück, also sehr viel später. Aber das Problem, das tauchte schon relativ früh auf, aber Einstein hat das für unmöglich gehalten, dass es so was Verrücktes in seiner Theorie geben könnte. Also Körper, aus denen dann kein Licht mehr entweichen kann.
Weil es sich einfach so viel Masse ansammelt, dass einfach die Gravitation stärker ist.
Als jede andere Kraft. Also jede andere Kraft. Eigentlich ist das nicht so überraschend, denn das kann man sich leicht überlegen, dass wenn man sozusagen einen Körper klein genug macht und die Gravitation sozusagen fast auf den Punkt zurückführt, dass es stärker als jede andere Kraft ist. Aber man hatte Schwierigkeiten, sich das vorzustellen. Einstein hat versucht, Gegenbeweise zu liefern und so weiter. Also das ist ein Beispiel, die Gravitationswellen, da hat er immer wieder geschwankt. Die hat er zwar vorhergesagt, dann hat er später versucht, die Vorhersage zurückzunehmen. Da war er sich auch nicht so ganz sicher. Und das ist ja auch mathematisch sehr kompliziert mit den Gravitationswellen, ob die eigentlich aus seiner Theorie folgen würden oder nicht. Aber das für mich am erstaunlichste ist am Ende, dass diese Theorie, wir haben ja jetzt gesehen, mit wie wenig Wissen sie eigentlich gebaut wurde, 1915, dass die immer noch die Theorie ist, die jetzt sozusagen das Universum in seinen großen Skalen, Entstehungen des Universums, Big Bang, Expandieren des Universums, Schwarze Löcher, Gravitationswellen, alles das, was es auch an aufregenden Neuigkeiten gibt in der heutigen Kosmologie, das findet immer noch im Rahmen dieser Theorie statt.
Das passt immer noch alles.
Das passt immer noch. Und da kriegt man doch diese beiden Momente, die wir am Anfang diskutiert haben, ganz gut mit. Also auf der einen Seite gibt es da eine erstaunliche Kontinuität. Und die, glaube ich, ist auch die Erklärung, warum das möglich ist, weil die Theorie von Einstein war zwar neu in ihren fundamentalen Auffassungen von Raum und Zeit, aber auf der anderen Seite hat sie sozusagen das Wissensgebäude der Physik umgebaut, der klassischen Physik umgebaut. Das heißt, sie hat die Elemente weiterverwendet, die schon Newton und andere entwickelt hatten, hat sie nur sozusagen neu zusammengesetzt. Und das heißt, man kriegt Brüche und Kontinuitäten hier zusammen. Ohne die Kontinuität wäre es geradezu ein Wunder, warum diese Theorie immer noch so erklärungsmächtig ist. Also wenn das so ist, wie andere sich das vorgestellt haben, Paradigmen wechseln oder Falsifizierungen von Popper und so weiter, dann müsste ja im Grunde so eine Art ständiger Theorienwechsel stattfinden, es sei denn, er wird sozusagen durch soziale Mechanismen verändert. Aber was wir in Wirklichkeit sehen, ist jetzt auch nicht die absolute Kontinuität, weil es ja solche Brüche gibt, aber doch sozusagen eine Langlebigkeit, die ihrerseits, glaube ich, was Überraschendes hat.
Ja und etwas namensgebendes, weil letztlich ist ja der Begriff Raumzeit auch von ihm geprägt worden oder ist er so in der Form auch schon vorher gehandelt worden?
Nein, wir haben eine große Figur vergessen, die also gerade für diesen Begriff Raumzeit nicht vergessen werden sollte, das ist Hermann Minkowski, der Göttinger Mathematiker, der der Erste gewesen ist, der gesehen hat, dass das, was Einstein mit der speziellen Relativität sehe, und zwar um 1908 herum geschaffen hatte, und so hat es Einstein erstmal gar nicht gesehen, eine Art neuer Geometrie ist von Raum und Zeit. Der hat gesagt, jetzt verschwinden Raum und Zeit in ihrer separaten Existenz und das genau die Theorie, die Einstein formuliert hatte, die kann man jetzt noch mal sehen als eine vierdimensionale Geometrie von drei Raum- und einer Zeitdimension. Und Einstein hat das zunächst für eine interessante Weise. Minkowski war Einsteins Lehrer, als er in Zürich war, aber hat er alles nicht so ernst genommen. Er hat es auch nicht ernst genommen, als Minkowski dann auch sehr früh, also sehr früh 1999, ein Stein, Minkowski natürlich. Ja, war es halt so mit den Lehrern. Und der Minkowski hat dann diese Theorie als Geometrie, so ist man diese Lorenz-Transformation auch als Drehungen in so einem vierdimensionalen, heute nennen wir das auch Minkowski-Raum, sich vorstellen kann. Und Einstein hat es zunächst mal für eine mathematische Spielerei gehalten, bis er dann auf diese schwierigen mathematischen Problemen mit der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie gestoßen hat und die kann man nur lösen, wenn man diese vierdimensionale Auffassung von Raumzeit als Grundlage nimmt. Und was Minkowski gemacht hat, ist dann sozusagen ein vierdimensionales, statisches Raumzeitgerüst. Und was Einstein dann in der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie gemacht hat, er hat gesagt, das ist eine bewegliche Bühne, die selber am Geschehen teilnimmt. Das ist eine dynamische Raumzeit-Bühne, die ihrerseits durch die physikalischen Prozesse, durch Energie und Materie beeinflusst wird. Also die Krümmung ist ein dynamischer Effekt.
Und da leben wir jetzt in dieser gekrümmten Raumzeit. Das ist sozusagen der eigentliche Äther.
Ja, das ist für Einstein selber eine gute Formulierung. Einstein selber ist zum Teil wieder genau zu diesen Formulierungen zurückgekehrt. Weil der Äther ist ja im Grunde sowas gewesen wie ein Raum, aber ein Raum mit physikalischen Eigenschaften. Die einzige Eigenschaft, die er dann nicht wieder zurückbekommen hat, ist irgendwie einen Bewegungszustand zu haben und ein mechanisches Medium zu sein. Also in dem Sinne doch kein Äther, aber im Sinne der Tatsache, dass Raum und Zeit physikalische Eigenschaften haben und nicht nur so ein Hintergrund sind, vor dem sich alles wesentlich abspielt, sondern die nehmen an dem Geschehen teil. Es ist sozusagen, es gibt nichts, was einen Hintergrund der Einstellung hat. Wenn man alle Materie aus dem Universum und alle Energie wegnehmen würde, nach klassischer Vorstellung würde Raum und Zeit da bleiben, aber nach der Vorstellung der Allgemeinen Relativität würde eben nichts da bleiben. Weil sie erst generiert werden durch die Materie und durch die Energie.
Weil wir, jeder von uns sie beeinflusst und damit eben auch erst mit schafft.
Aber in kleinem Maße nur.
In sehr kleinem Maße. Aber beständig. Was ja noch so ein anderer wissenschaftlicher Knackpunkt war in der Sicht von Einstein, wenn ich das richtig überblicke, ist ja sein Verhältnis zu diesen ganzen quanten-mechanischen Prozessen. Er hat ja im Prinzip mit der Relativitätstheorie den Blick für das große und ganze, eröffnet. Alles, was weiter noch ging, als er das wahrscheinlich selber am Anfang gedacht hat. Aber im Prinzip sind seine Theorien ja die Basis für das Universum, das Verhältnis aller Planeten, der Materie etc. Ein Blick, den er aber hier nicht geliefert hat, ist der Blick ins Allerkleinste. Man ist ja geneigt dann zu sagen, naja, wenn diese Theorie auf alles passt und immer hält, dann lässt sie sich vermutlich wirklich auf alles anwenden, aber irgendwo endet das ja dann auch. Und das waren andere Wissenschaftler, die dort Leistungen vollbracht haben, wo er so ein bisschen in Skepsis war.
Ja, aber die Skepsis ist ja eigentlich erst ein Spätzustand. Er war ja anfangs sehr stark beteiligt an der Schaffung der Quantentheorie. Wie gesagt, dieser Begriff der Lichtquanten oder heute der Photonen, das stammt ja von ihm. Also er war da sogar ein radikaler Pionier, während andere versucht haben, noch den Teppich der klassischen Physik zu flicken. Hat er schon gesagt, wir brauchen da was völlig Neues. Und er hat für die Geburt der Quantentheorie wesentliches geleistet. Und ich glaube, das Wichtigste neben allen Einzelentdeckungen, die er da auch gemacht hat, ist erstmal allen Beteiligten deutlich zu machen, das ist eine völlig andere und eine völlig neue Theorie, die da entsteht. Und die brauchen wir auch. Er war damit den Lösungen, die dann später Heisenberg, Schrödinger, Bohr, Born und viele andere geliefert haben, nicht mehr einverstanden, weil er nicht daran glauben wollte, dass die Natur in ihrem Wesen nach statistisch ist, wie es die heutige Quantenmechanik will. Also das macht aber dann leicht vergessen, dass er bis dahin, und wir reden jetzt über Mitte der 20er Jahre, unglaublich viele Einzelleistungen beigebracht hat.
Dafür auch seinen Nobelpreis bekommen hat.
Dafür, der für den sogenannten photoelektrischen Effekt seinen Nobelpreis bekommen hat. Aber auch die physikalischen Grundlagen des heute allgegenwärtigen Lasers. Also Einstein hat keine Laser konstruiert, aber er hat sozusagen die Eigenschaften der Strahlung, die dem zugrunde liegen, als er es da wirklich verstanden und analysiert. Also großartige Beiträge. Aber aufgrund seiner späteren Distanz.
Also ohne Einstein kein Laserschwert.
Ja, ohne Einstein kein Laserschwert. Genau. Also geschweige denn Warpantrieb. Ja, ich meine, das sollte man da nicht vergessen. Das ist auch, ich habe es natürlich, wenn man so kurz referiert, immer ist man immer unterkomplex. Also Einstein hat da oft geschwankt, hat die Widersprüche gesehen. Ich finde es unterm Strich dann doch auch beeindruckend, dass er sich einfach die Freiheit genommen hat, da auch später einfach anderer Meinung zu sein und der Quantentheorie hat sich auch nicht einfach abgewandt, sondern hat er dann weiterhin Herausforderungen gestellt. Es gibt dann diese berühmten Paradoxien, die er formuliert hat und die wirkten als Triebkraft für die Weiterentwicklung der Quantentheorie. Gibt es wirklich keine versteckten Variablen, sodass man diese ganzen Statistischen Effekte wieder auf unsichtbare Teilchen zurückführen können? Das hat er vorangetrieben, indem er das immer wieder in Frage gestellt hat. Und das, was wir heute unter Verschränkungen und so weiter verstehen, das hat er mitbefördert durch seine kritischen Fragestellungen. Also Wissenschaft ist auch, das darf man nicht vergessen, in einem großen Maße Dialog und Austausch. Und da sollte man nicht immer ausschließlich nachher sortieren, wer hat da die richtigen und die falschen Positionen gehabt. Manchmal ist eine falsche Position eine stärkere Triebkraft als einfach so ein laues Zustimmen zu irgendwas. Aber am Ende ist es schon richtig. Eine der großen Herausforderungen der Physik heute ist, wir haben diese große Theorie des Universums, die Relativitätstheorie und wir haben die Theorie, die vor allen Dingen die mikroskopische Welt erklärt, die Quantentheorie. Beides muss aber irgendwie zusammenhängen. Und die Frage ist, wie genau und wie geht es und wie kommen wir darauf? Und das Problem allerdings ist dabei, dass man so wenig empirische Handhabe hat. Also viele der Probleme haben sich in der Vergangenheit dadurch lösen können, dass man irgendwelche Gegenstände hat, für die beide, für zwei Theorien, die man zusammenbringen musste, werden Elektromagnetismus genannt, hat man so ein Phänomen wie Induktion oder so, da spielen dann plötzlich beide Aspekte eine Rolle. Bei der sogenannten Quantengravitation hat man einfach fast nichts außer Prozessen wie Entstehung des Universums, über die man ja auch noch relativ wenig weiß, die einen zwingen würden, beide Theorien wirklich anzuwenden und erst aus so einer Zusammenführung der beiden Theorien an solchen Grenzproblemen würde man erkennen können, wie die sich eigentlich zueinander verhalten und verhalten müssen. Aber ich glaube, das ist im Wesentlichen doch das Problem der mangelnden Empirie.
Nun hatte ja Einsteins Arbeit nicht nur Einfluss auf die Wissenschaft als solche, sondern hat ja auch eine Vielzahl von konkreten technologischen Erfindungen und Innovationen nach sich gezogen, wir hatten gerade das Beispiel mit dem Laser, der halt einfach so erstmal noch gar nicht denkbar gewesen ist und der heutzutage eine der nützlichsten Dinge überhaupt ist für zahlreiche Anwendungen auf allen Feldern. Eine Konsequenz war natürlich dann auch das Atomzeitalter. Welche Rolle hat Einstein da konkret gehabt? Er war ja dann schon immer ein Kritiker der Kriege gewesen, des ersten wie des zweiten Weltkrieges, aber fand sich ja dann auch später in dieser Nachkriegszeit, die ja eigentlich auch noch eine Kriegszeit war, eine Kaltkriegszeit, auch gefühlt auf der falschen Seite wieder. Wie ist Einstein damit umgegangen? Was war da seine Rolle?
Also Einstein ist in vielfältiger Weise eben mit diesen großen Entwicklungen des 20. Jahrhunderts verbunden gewesen. Seine berühmteste Formel, die natürlich in der Tat auch etwas zu tun hat mit der Nuklearenergie, e.g. mc², ist eine Konsequenz der speziellen Relativitätstheorie gewesen. Diese weitgehenden Wirkungen der Formel waren natürlich damals nicht absehbar. Einstein hat sich im Laufe des ersten Weltkrieges sozusagen weiter politisiert und sich gegen die Kollegen auch gestellt, die Unterstützer des deutschen Militarismus waren. Er hat sich in der Weimarer Republik sehr klar zur Demokratie bekannt und auch versucht, Friedensstiften zu wirken, in den damals noch sehr virulenten Nachkriegskonflikten ausgleichend zu wirken. Er war einer der wenigen deutschen Wissenschaftler, die überhaupt in Ländern wie Frankreich oder so sprechen konnten und hat dort Brücken gebaut, auch durch seine Reisen später. Er hat dann natürlich sehr früh auch die Gefahren des aufziehenden Nationalsozialismus erkannt. Er selber hat ihm Morddrohungen geschickt. Er ist Opfer antisemitischer Propaganda geworden. Sein Freund Walter Rathenau wurde hier in Berlin ermordet. Also der sah schon sehr früh die Gefahren, die da aufzogen und musste dann emigrieren. Hat dann durchaus auch mit Mühen eine neue Heimat in Amerika gefunden und hat sich dann einspannen lassen, so muss man es vielleicht sagen, in die Überlegung von anderen Emigranten wie Leo Szilard und anderen amerikanischen Wissenschaftlern, dass man irgendwie damit rechnen müsse, dass die Nazis eine Atombombe bauen würden. Und hat dann einen berühmten Brief unterschrieben, den er sich selber verfasst hat an den damaligen Präsidenten Roosevelt, in dem er vor diesen Entwicklungen warnte und im Grunde die Amerikaner mit aufforderte, solche Entwicklungen zu machen. Das ist nun wirklich, da ist er eingespannt gewesen, man versuchte sich durch den damals sehr bekannten Namen Einstein Gehör zu verschaffen bei den entsprechenden Regierungskreisen und auf diese Weise eine Entwicklung in Gang zu setzen. Als das Projekt, das Manhattan-Projekt, dann wirklich in Gang gesetzt wurde, hatte Einstein nichts damit zu tun. Der wäre auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht zugelassen worden, weil er eben auch als ein Kritiker von Rassismus und allem Möglichen in Amerika schon unter Beobachtung stand des FBIs und jedenfalls keine sehr Vertrauen mit seinen radikaldemokratischen linken Weltanschauungen eher eine Person war, die man auch skeptisch beurteilte. Und er hat sich dann aber nach dem Krieg noch viel vehementer, nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg jetzt für Probleme der internationalen Verständigung und der Kontrolle der nuklearen Bewaffnung eingesetzt. Er ist dann ganz gegen Ende seines Lebens noch Mitbegründer der Pack-Wash-Bewegung geworden hat. Das sogenannte Russell-Einstein-Manuskript ist sozusagen praktisch in seinen letzten Lebenstagen noch entstanden. Und hat sich immer wieder auch in seinen politischen Schriften für sowas wie eine Weltregierung, für eine Weltkontrolle von Waffen ausgesprochen. Manche sagen sehr naiv, sehr idealistisch. Aber auf der anderen Seite war er natürlich auch ein Name, der gehört wurde und der im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen diesen Anliegen seine Stimme gab. Andere haben, weiß ich, die Wasserstoppbombe entwickelt oder sich für eine Nuklearrüstung der Bundeswehr ausgesprochen. Große Wissenschaftler. Und Einstein hat dagegen gehalten, aufgrund eben auch, die Wurzeln waren wahrscheinlich in seiner frühen Gegnerschaft zu jeder Form von Militarismus begründet, aber dann eben auch in seinen vielfältigen und leidvollen Erfahrungen mit der Politik des 20. Jahrhunderts. Und er hat Wissenschaft immer als eine Art Menschheitsanliegen verstanden. Einem Versuch sozusagen dem Alltagsgewirr zu entrinnen und sich an einer höheren Objektivität zu orientieren. Da hat er immer auch die Chance gesehen, einer gemeinsamen menschheitlichen Perspektive auf die Wirklichkeit aus der man vielleicht auch die Kraft schöpfen kann, sozusagen Frieden und Versöhnung in den politischen Verhältnissen zu stiften. Also ich sehe Einstein als jemand, der natürlich kein ausgesprochener Politiker oder schon gar kein politischer Prophet war, aber der sich einfach verpflichtet gefühlt hat aufgrund seiner eigenen Berühmtheit, die er eben auch als ein Kapital gesehen hat, von dem er meinte, dass man es einsetzen müsse zum Besten der Menschheit, immer wieder in Fragen Stellung zu nehmen, auch in Fragen, als der Staat Israel gegründet wurde, als die hebräische Universität gegründet wurde. Er gehört wirklich zu den Mitbegründern der hebräischen Universität, hat sich zugleich aber zu einzelnen politischen Dingen immer auch kritisch geäußert und hat sich einfach die Freiheit genommen, egal wo er war, nicht einfach konform zu sein, sondern Dinge zu hinterfragen, so wie er es natürlich auch aus seiner Wissenschaft gewohnt war. Also da sehe ich schon auch eine gewisse Kohärenz in seinem Verhalten.
Er ist auch so ein bisschen die Antithese zu Leuten wie Werner von Braun, der berühmt geworden ist mit, das ist nicht meine Abteilung, das ist mein Department so, wo die Raketen da runtergehen, wer fragt schon, wo sie herkamen, sondern für ihn war eigentlich dieses Gewissen wichtig und stilbildend und auch Leitmotiv seiner Arbeit bis zum Schluss.
Er hat eben auch ganzheitlich gedacht. Also bis zum Schluss hat er an einer vereinheitlichen Feldtheorie gearbeitet und vorher hat er über den Kosmos gearbeitet und er hat auch eben die Welt als ein Weltsystem angesehen, aus dem man sich nicht einfach rausziehen kann, indem man eine Perspektive einnimmt, die sich auf Spezialprobleme konzentriert oder indem man gleich ins Außerplanetarische geht und sagt, das Gewühle hier unten interessiert mich nicht. Sondern er hat es sozusagen aus dieser umfassenden Perspektive und aus diesen umfassenden Zusammenhängen gesehen. Das sieht man wirklich in vielfältigen Äußerungen, ob sie sich nun auf die Wissenschaft oder ob sie sich auf die Weltpolitik beziehen. Er hat immer das Ganze im Blick gehabt und hat alle Trennungen und Unterscheidungen für vorläufig und vielleicht auch nicht für das Relevanteste gehalten.
Was kann man so rausziehen als Wissenschaftler heute von dem Leben von Albert Einstein?
Man kann es natürlich nicht einfach in irgendeiner Form nachmachen. Vorbilder sind immer schwer, weil sich die Umstände radikal geändert haben. Wir haben ja schon gesagt, die Wissenschaft war damals eine kleine Gruppe. Aber auch diese Sprecherrolle, die er dann haben konnte, war natürlich auch dann den ganz spezifischen Umständen der Zeit geschuldet. Die Physik hat in der Nachkriegszeit die Rolle einer Leitwissenschaft gespielt, weil sie in allen, gerade auch den militärischen Bereichen, so unheuer wichtig war. Das hat natürlich umgekehrt einer Figur wie Einstein, der Physiker war, einer der größten seiner Zeit, diese enorme Prominenz gegeben. Und daran sieht man schon, das hat sich heute geändert. Die Physik ist nicht mehr unbedingt die Leitwissenschaft. Und es kann keinen zweiten Einstein in dieser Weise geben. Also wenn man ihn als Vorbild begreift und von ihm lernen will, dann muss man diese veränderten Zeitumstände immer mitberücksichtigen. Und sollte jetzt nicht einfach davon ausgehen, es sei eine besondere Aufgabe von physikern, die mit den Fundamenten der Physik oder der Kosmologie beschäftigt sind, sich nun zu Menschheitsproblemen zu äußern. Das kann genauso gut jemand machen, der zum Beispiel Festkörperphysik betreibt, oder der Chemiker ist oder der Biologe ist. Also ich sage nur, mutatis mutandis. Man muss das auf die heutige Situation beziehen. Aber der ganzheitliche Blick, ich finde, der ist nach wie vor vorbildlich. Wenn wir heute von Anthropozäen reden, von einem Zeitalter, einer geologischen Epoche, die von den Einwirkungen des Menschen bestimmt wird, dann kommen wir um einen solchen ganzheitlichen Blick gar nicht mehr drum herum. Also alle Aspekte der Veränderung unserer Umwelt sind gar nicht mehr lokal zu begreifen, zum einen, und sind auch nicht mehr nach Disziplinengrenzen zu begreifen. Insofern kann man vielleicht einstellen, auch als Vorläufer einer Art von Integration von Wissenschaft und Wissenschaft und Gesellschaft begreifen, die bestimmte traditionelle Schranken, die letztlich aus dem 19. Jahrhundert kommen, anzeigen, in welcher Richtung die zu überwinden wären. Nämlich stärker an den konkreten Problemen orientiert. So über den Dingen schwebend Einstein manchmal erscheinen mag, wenn er dann den Journalisten die Zunge rausstreckt und mit den Pantoffeln durch Princeton latscht und an seiner vereinheitlichen Feldtheorie arbeitet. Da sollte man den realitätshaltigen Einstein nicht vergessen.
Ich sehe vor allem so einen Einstein, der bereit war, Verantwortung zu übernehmen, dem das alles nicht egal war. Und der sozusagen ein globaler Denker war in jeder Hinsicht.
Und der gemeinsam mit jemandem wie Freud versucht hat zu verstehen, was denn nun die Ursachen für Kriege sind. Das ist eine Frage, die ihn auch bewegt hat. Da hat er weniger zu beitragen können als zu den Fragen der Gravitation. Aber es hat ihn ebenso wenig locker gelassen, was denn nun dieses in der Menschheitsgeschichte zu bedeuten hat.
Man möchte sich wünschen, dass die Wissenschaftsgeschichte vor allem auch so Personen wie ihn in den wissenschaftlichen Diskurs immer wieder hereinträgt. Und insofern ist ja Ihre Aufgabe eigentlich gut gewählt.
Ja, ich hoffe mal, wir bemühen uns. Was anderes kann man nicht tun.
Ich bedanke mich sehr für die Ausführung.
Ich danke für Ihre Fragen.
Ja, das war ein schöner Einblick hier bei Raumzeit. Und ich bedanke mich auch bei allen natürlich wieder hier fürs Zuhören. Geht auch bald weiter. Und ich werde auch ein wenig in diesen in den letzten Folgen eingenommenen Pfad weiterlaufen. Ausnahmsweise mal ein ausgetretener Pfad. Und ansonsten bleibt es natürlich bunt wie immer. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.